SPEAKER:
>> Android phones to Android
cars droid Android
Android android Patrick Brady AJ
Kimbembe Chen X. Xiao Patrick
Brady AJ Kimbembe Chen Xiao
automatic Android Auto Chrysler
Renault         Renault Volvo
WhatsApp          WhatsApp Allo
audible         audible Spotify
Bluetooth I.
Bluetooth ii    IO Google Google
I/O Google
I.                      Google
I/O Google Google IO Nougat
Maserati cluster Maserati
Android Fiat Chrysler
UConnect          UConnect
system combr       combr demoing
CES Fiat Chrysler
Chrysler Panasonic Harman
Qualcomm Audi infotainment
Alfons Pfaller head of
connected           connected
car and infotainment at
infotainment at app app Alfons
Pfaller Alfons Pfaller la Google
I/O Google Earth street view
and search Alfons Henrik Green
Alfons Pfaller Volvo Henrik
Green IOT Pokemon Pokemons
Pokemon Go bespoke layout siloed
lout layouts rotary
hybrid        hybrid nat and lo
predictive mod layerty modular
modularity is key module arty
modular HMI API Waze SMS     SMS
voice centric Google assistant
Chen Georgia Google Assistant AJ
podcasts podcast ininvocation
dialog dialogs Java C fortune
cookie        cookie code code
fusion Codefucious for true
happiness prefer interfaces over
abstract classes.  Cascal IoT
IoT     IoT IoT IoT automation
Actions On Google.
PATRICK BRADY:
AJ KIMBEMBE:
CHEN XIAO:
PATRICK BRADY:
AJ KIMBEMBE:
CHEN XIAO:
PATRICK BRADY:
AJ KIMBEMBE:
CHEN XIAO:
PATRICK BRADY:  Blah blah blah.
AJ KIMBEMBE:  Blah blah blah.
CHEN XIAO:  Blah blah blah.
SPEAKER:  Test test test test
test test test test test test
test
test test test test test
blah blah blah blah #
blah
.
SPEAKER:
>> 6
>>
Jooch
PATRICK BRADY:
Hello
Hello and welcome
welcome to Google IO2017.  I'm
Patrick Brady from      from the
Android         Android team at
Google and I'm     I'm here
with AJ    AJ and Chen      Chen
to give      give you an update
on Android         Android in
cars.  We have a lot to cover
today       today.  Let's
Let's buckle        buckle up
and get driving
9 auto industry is    is really
heating         heating up.  I
think that's no secret.  We see
cars rapidly         rapidly
transforming from      from
disconnected machines
machines to paurful
paurful connected computers
connected
computers           computers on
wheels.  The controls
controls are shifting from
mechanical knob      knobs and
dials       dials to software
to software-
software-defined
interfaces.
We also      also see a
convergence
convergence between the mobile
and     and auf         and auto
automotive      motive
world.  Creating
Creating exciting opportunities
opportunities to
revolutionize
revolutionize the way we
interact with our cars today
today.  Through open
software platform
platforms, artificial
intelligence and vibrant
vibrant developer
developer ecosystems
ecosystems.  Android Auto is
is an effort from      from
Google and our parents to bring
bring all of our advance
s           advances to create
create a seamless
seamless connected
connected experience for
drivers everywhere
everywhere.  It's still early
early days, but today
today anyone with an
Android-compatible
this at work from their favorite
favorite Alfons
Pfallers right from      from
the car's display
display.  We continue to expand
expand the number of
Android Auto compatible
compatible cars
through great partnership
partnerships with
over 50    50 car brands.  There
are over 300 Android Auto
Auto compatible
compatible cars available today
today.  Including
Including first launch
launches from      from
Chrysler          Chrysler,
Renault         Renault, Volvo
Volvo in the last
last few months alone
alone.  And that's triple
triple the number from
from just one     one year ago.
It's well on its way to
becoming          becoming a
standard feature         feature
in every new car.
car.
Of course we know that not
everyone          everyone has a
new car.  And so we've also
also made the Android Auto
Auto Alfons Pfaller
Auto app
available as a stand
standalone feature
feature.  This opens       opens
up the platform
platform and eco     ecosystem
to many millions of drivers no
matter        matter
matter what kind of car they
drive.  Whether you're looking
looking to stay connected
connected with
WhatsApp          WhatsApp,
Facebook          Facebook
messenger           messenger or
Allo, the Alfons Pfallers
Allo,
the apps are now available.  And
before anyone asks, Waze is
is hitting b   beta      beta so
we're exciting
exciting to welcome them
them as well.
[ Applause ]
of
car they drive.  Whether you're
looking to stay connected with
WhatsApp, Facebook messenger or
Allo, the apps are now
available.  And before anyone
asks, Waze is hitting beta so
we're exciting to welcome them
as well.
[ Applause ].  We're seeing
seeing strong growth
growth on the developer
developer front as
well.  In fact we've seen a 50%
% increase in the auto mf
in the auto-enabled
auto-enabled app
app
auto-enabled apps in the play
store since last      last year.
But            year.  But none
of this would matter
matter if    if we didn't
we didn't have users
users, right?  I'm     I'm
happy to say Android Auto
Auto usage is    is growing
growing like crazy
crazy as well.  Heefr
Heefr's where we were at Google
I/O 2016, and here is    is
where we are today       today
at I/    I/O2017.  We've seen a
10X growth        growth in
usage       usage over the last
last year along and the
strong trajectory
trajectory continues.  But this
is    is just the beginning.
And we're really more excited
about       about where Android
is    is going on the road ahead
ahead.  Last      Last
year at IO we announced
announced that we're
building          building auto
automotive      motive
features          features right
into the Android platform
platform to make it a
turn      turnkey solution
solution for cars.
Every bit as much      much as
automotive platform
platform as it is a mobile
platform today       today.
We're doing this because
because we believe open
platform          platforms are
powerful          powerful
powerful enablers of eco
ecosystems.  They reduce the
cost      cost of development
and they speed time to market.
In a sense they accelerate
innovation
innovation.  We're also
also doing this because
because it enables us    us to
deliver an even      even more
seamless driving         driving
experience, with all the
information, controls
controls and connectivity
available slew
available through a single
system that's infused
infused with the driver's
identity          identity,
their       their digital life
life and context.
context.  We listen
listened and learned from
partners who     who had already
brought Android         Android
into automotive
automotive and we worked
worked hard to solve the
challenges they hit along the
way.  A robust        robust
andful        andful featured
Bluetooth stack       stack, a
standard way to connect with
with cabin       cabin
controls          controls, and
a system that boosts
boosts instantly
instantly.  At Google I/O
At Google I/O
2016 we showed        showed
this all off with Android
Android Nougat
Nougat powering
powering the entire in-
in-car experience of a concept
Maserati          Maserati.  The
windows         windows, doors
doors, heating
heating, the instrument cluster
cluster.  As much
much as we really loved
loved that Maserati
Maserati and I would really like
to take it home, it was a
concept.  And I think what we
want, and what we think you all
want, is    is to see really
cars running         running
modern Android-poured
Android-powered
systems         systems.  The
traction          traction we're
seeing        seeing in the
industry is    is pretty amazing
amazing.  Just a few
short months after the official
Android         Android Nougat
Nougat release, several
several of our partners
partners were demoing
Android-powered
Android-powered infotainment
systems         systems at CES
CES 2017 including
including Fiat      Fiat
Chrysler Android         Android
Nougat powered         powered
UConnect          UConnect
system.   :           system:
Earlier         Earlier this
week an automotive
automotive industry heavy weight
weight with a reputation
reputation for
building          building some
of the most      most advanced
systems         systems on the
market.  Please join      join
me in welcome ing
welcoming Alfons Pfaller head of
connected           connected
car and     and infotainment
infotainment at
Audi      Audi AG.
[ Applause ]
Patrick and our friends from
from Google, thank you very
very, very much      much
for being       being here
here.  For Audi      Audi
it's the third time that we are
here at I/    I/O and for Audi
Audi the Google I/O is    is
really a special event.  A
great event.  We have a very
very, very      very long-
long-time relationship
with Google.  And we have been
able to launch        launch a
lot of really cool services
services over the last
years       years.  We started
with Google
Earth       Earth, street view,
search and a lot of things
things.  And now it's a
really big next step is coming
coming.  If if    if
you're looking         looking
on the picture, on this picture
we see a brand new Audi
interior          interior
design.  This design is    is
based on the best      best in
class digital cockpit
cockpit technology.  And we see
here three
absolute, absolute automotive
automotive high-
high-end display
displays in the front, and
additional            additional
display         displays in t
the.  Based on this digital
cockpit         cockpit, we are
able to bring       bring in a
really, really amazing
amazing design.  And really
straight
straightforward excellent
excellent user
experience.  And in this design,
we are doing a seamless
seamless integration
integration of em
embedded Android
Android.  And I think that is
is really, really epic
epic step.  If I'm     I'm to do
a short summary         summary
in terms of time.  We are
silicon solution partners
partners, really high-
high-end computing
computing inside the
car.  Next step is    is this
mobile communication.  We are
connecting all cars.  All cars
with high-       high-speed IDE
and very              IDE.  So
it's a whole cloud eco
ecosystem.
This em    embedded an druf
bedded an Android
bedded Android
Android         Android.
We ask     ask to invite you
to    to, to invite all of you
to participate in our
automotive            automotive
development.  So thanks very
much      much and looking
looking forward to see
this concept on our show car
outside.  And
outside.  Thank you very much
much.
[ Applause ]
Thanks.  Thank you, Alfons.  We
couldn't be more excited to
partner         partner with
Audi      Audi again to bring
bring an drud
bring Android
Android into their
their future cars.  But you
can't build an eco     ecosystem
with just one partnership
partnership, right?
And that's why I'm     I'm
happy to say that one of the
of the industry's most
most innovative
innovative companies, Volvo
Volvo, is also putting
their weight        weight
behind the Android
Android in-     in-car eco
ecosystem.  I'm     I'm happy to
welcome         welcome up
Henrik Green       Green senior
vice president
president of research and
development at Volvo       Volvo
car group to tell you about
their       their new system.
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  Thank you, Patrick
Patrick.
Good afternoon
afternoon, and thank you to
friends at Google for inviting
us    us to this great event.
Thank you for the sun and most
most of all thank you for
the sun     sunscreen.  I
haven't looked        looked at
the mirror yet     yet so I'm
I'm not sure but ifl     ifl
definitely burned
sure but I am definitely burned
burned on the right side.
I mean we have worked
worked with Google for a number
of years       years on
different projects and of course
the recent an drud
recent Android
is    is a fantastic
fantastic success of that.  But
today       today we're here to
announce that our partnership is
is going to the next level.
We are together
together with Google team here
to develop the next generation
of connected           connected
car infotainment
infotainment.  And as always for
Volvo       Volvo, it's very
important           important
for us    us to create
create a completely seamless
solution          solution,
whether user --         user --
where the user experience is
is at the heart of everybody
everybody and that we
can provide a better life and a
better experience through the
integrated use of this
infotainment
infotainment system.  Now, the
design of the        of the UX
system plays of course an
enormous important
important role.  But at the part
of it, it's the operating
operating system.  And
here we strongly
strongly believe that together
together with Google we
will develop the next generation
based on the Android platform
platform.  So again,
it's to you     you out there.
You are the developer
developers.  You     You are now
the people and the brain power
that will bring this experience
to life in the future cars.  So
be with us    us here and show
that we can make the best
best connected infotainment
system and car experience out
there.  Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
It's pretty cool, right?  I
definitely, I definitely
encourage you to go check out
the demo      demos that Audi
Audi and Volvo       Volvo
are showing         showing in
the Android         Android and
IOT                 Android and
IoT booth       booths out
there.  They look even      even
bet inner person.  Sadly
Sadly I have to say, we're not
giving        giving out any
free cars this year at I/
I/O.  So you have to make do
with a T-shirt      -shirt.  But
Audi and Volvo       Volvo are
really true      true pea
nearest         nearest in
automotive            automotive
electrons
automotive electronics
electronics in
infotainment.  We're really,
really excited about       about
that.  With the Android
Android auto app on phones
phones, with 300 kraud
300 Android
Android auto compatible
compatible car models
models, and with built-
built-in systems
systems hitting         hitting
the road soon, we're pushing
pushing forward to
revolutionize
revolutionize the way we stay
connected           connected in
our cars, create ing
creating a safe      safe
safe and seamless
seamless connected
connected experience for drivers
everywhere
everywhere.  But a big part of
the             part of the
driver's digital life, as Henrik
and Alfons said, is    is the
applications
applications and services
services they use
throughout their       their
digital life on their
their other desize the
other desizes.
And                     other
devices and we need to bring
bring the eco
ecosystem along for the ride.  I
would like to welcome
welcome up on stage AJ Kimbembe
from      from the Android Auto
Auto UX team to talk about
about what this all means
for developer
developers.
[ Applause ]
Patrick.  And hi    hi,
everyone          everyone.  My
name is AJ    AJ and I'm
AJ and I am the lead
designer          designer for
Android         Android in-
in-car infotainment.  Patrick
already         already detailed
detailed how we've
been hard at work to make
Android         Android the best
best possible infotainment
platform          platform with
improvement
improvement to Bluetooth
Bluetooth, boot time,
car controls          controls,
radio, car sensors, cluster
clusters and so on.  But
Android is    is not only a
great platform
platform.  It's also      also
an entire eco     ecosystem of
aps                  ecosystem
of apps and services
services.  But first I would
like to talk about why     why
are we doing this.  So this is
is natural         natural
photo of our field research.
This driver is trying
trying to catch Pokemons
Pokemons while at the
wheel and you can see the family
crossing          crossing in
the background
background.  Don't
background.
Don't worry       worry,
everybody is safe      safe.
This is    is not a stock image
image.  This is    is our
researchers
researchers in the car with the
drivers out on the roads
roads.  Now if    if this is
happening           happening
with our researchers
researchers in the vehicle.
Our internal research shows
shows our people drivers
want to stay connected
connected and they may resort
to use their phones
phones to do so and that can
lead to situations that are
are fundamental
fundamentally unsafe
unsafe.  We want to help drivers
stay connected
connected with interfaces that
are safe      safe and
predictable
predictable.  So I want to talk
about       about three things
things here.  First, why
why it's complex to design
services          services for
the car.  What Android is    is
doing to help as a platform then
then, and finally
finally what are the various
ways you can integrate with
Android auto as a developer
developer.  Okay.
What is    is making
making designing apps and
services          services for
the car specific, exciting
exciting but also
also challenging
challenging?  Android is    is a
plample              is a
platform          platform for
infotainment across
across wide range of possible
surface         surfaces, shapes
shapes, aspect
aspect ratio could be different
density         densities, Fidel
Fidelitys.  A car
interior is    is a meticulous
meticulously crafted
experience.  Everything is    is
optimize          optimized for
safety        safety of course,
course, but also
also to provide a specific
experience for each brand and
price points        points.
Display         Displays can be
can be big, small, wide,
tall, integrated
integrated or heads-
heads-up display
displays.  Android is    is a
plample              is a
platform          platform that
support all of this along with
the outputs, the input methods
methods are multiple as
well.  Touch screens
screens are more common in the
car, but inputs such      such
as rotary        rotary and
touch pads can be        can be
found as well.         well.
Android is    is a platform
platform that      that
supports that as well.
well.
Safety
Safety of course is    is our
priority          priority.  We
work really hard to reduce
driver disstruks
driver
distraction, visual distraction,
manual and cognitive
cognitive distraction.
distraction.  Our
internal research team works
works closely
closely with the broader
broader team to strengthen
to strengthen
understanding
understanding of driver-
driver-vehicle
driver-vehicle interaction.  And
so to get our feature
feature developments, our team
conduct research studies
studies the needs       needs
assessment
assessment, usability
usability evaluations
evaluations
quantitative
quantitative survey
surveys and formal        formal
driver distraction tefl
driver
distraction testing
testing as well.  A positive
working         working
relationship with
relationship
with external organization and
stays up to date with standards
so we do all that.  So partners
partners and developer
developers don't have
to do it.  So you can see
see our driving         driving
simulator is    is an expense
ive           expensive set
setup tha      up that
simulates driving conditions
conditions.  We use
it for many things including
including detection
detection response
task      task which is    is
one way we use to evaluate
cognitive loads       loads.  We
also      also use it for eye
tracking          tracking.  You
can see     see.  And we use
the glasses to see     see the
driver focusing
focusing on the road and
glancing          glancing at
the UI.  What I would like to
say it's a complex and expense
ive           expensive endeavor
endeavor and we are
doing all that so our partners
partners and drivers
don't have to worry       worry
so much about       about it.
Okay.  So now on to what
Android is    is doing to add
developer           developers.
So like we said earlier
earlier, we know drivers want
to stay connected
connected and want to have them
them with interfaces that
are safe      safe and
predictable
predictable.  The content
content, the context
and the fluid nature of digital
services          services can
make that a challenge.  The
content         content of in-
in-car infotainment used
used to be more predictable
predictable.  Now we
find we are designing
designing a system that is
is red toy safe      safely
bring into cars the services
services that we know
and use on platform
platforms and that we like as
well.  Android is    is a great
platform          platform for
modern        modern digital
services          services, on
phones        phones, atablets
atablets, on    on TVs
TVs, on wearables and now we
are bringing          bringing
that to cars as well.  The key
to adapt quickly         quickly
and efficiently
efficiently to the widedy ters
wide diversity is
is modularity
modularity.  Android is    is ab
straking          straking away
away
is abstracting
abstracting away      away the
inputs or outputting
outputs so developer
developers don't have to worry
about       about screen shapes
shapes or size
sizes or weather         weather
something is    is touch or
rotary        rotary.  Android
Android provides an in-
in-car platform
platform so divide
platform so
developer           developers
can focus on building
building innovative apps without
worrying about       about the
details       details.
One way Android         Android
does the heavy lifting
lifting for developer
developers is    is through
templates           templates.
templates.  We've
designed          designed a
system that enable automotive
automotive grade
templates t
templates.  Those templates
templates are designed
designed to    to
accommodate a variety of
regulatory concerns
concerns.  Like I don't have to
worry about       about what is
is the size      size tap
targets         targets or how
many      many items can be
can be display
displayed on one screen in a
country or region.  We take care
of that.  Another way we make
Android a predictable
predictable
experience is    is with apps.
Although          Although
powerful          powerful, the
app grid is    is not the most
most suitable
suitable metaphor for the
automotive            automotive
space.  We've identified
identified
identified the key areas
areas for the car and made it
easy to switch between them
them.  And it's not only in our
own Android Auto platform
platform.  You can see
this today       today for
example in the best      best in
class systems designed
designed by our partners
partners Audi      Audi
and Volvo       Volvo be sure to
check out the demo      demo s
demos right outside.
Here the most      most commonly
used      used functions
functions are elevated
elevated so drivers
can quickly         quickly and
safe      safely switch between
them      them without having to
make their       their way to
an           way to an app grid
grid.  We also      also
want the experience to feel
personal and tailored
tailored.  We work hard to make
sure that Android understands
understands when a
driver is    is in the car and
can optimize itself
itself to safely        safely
bring the driver's apps and
services          services.
Android is already built-
built-in with multiuser
support.  It's been a few years
years now and we are
fully leverage ing
leveraging this framework
framework in the
vehicle         vehicle to
enable frictionless
frictionless personalization
personalization.
We want to get to the point
where a driver can step into a
rental        rental car and
have an experience that is    is
personalize
personalized and ready
ready to drive.
Now on to the last      last
portion.  What are the different
ways that you can bring your
app or service into cars.
Android          .  Prauf
cars.
Android is    is a common
platform          platform that
millions of developer
developers already
already know how to build for.
If you are already invest
invested in the Android
Android ecodemocrat
ecosystem, we want to make
things        things easy for
you.  Android         Android as
a platform          platform
does the heavy lifting
lifting and provides
provides a set of tools
tools and API     APIs to
integrate easily with the car.
Our goal is    is to have
have one sinl               have
one single platform
platform across        across
every car.  Let's look      look
at that in more details.
details.
We want to be respectful of the
of the time and resources
developer           developers
commit to bring their
their app and services
services to the car.  That's why
why there are multiple ways
you can integrate with Android
Auto      Auto.  Depending
Depending on the
nature of your service, of
course.  For a few of those apps
it will require         require
a lot more effort
effort, a lot more design time
and possibly          possibly
more cost      cost as well.
well.  But for most of
the        of the app, it will
be         will be less time
involved          involved.
What we call full apps are
services          services that
are full control of what is
is display         displayed on
the screen.  I would take an
example         example here n
here.  Google maps
Maps is using dynamic
dynamic s           dynamics,
bringing          bringing a
full app experience
necessity a huge      huge
amount of human and technical
technical resources.
You have to think about
about tap target size      size,
contrast          contrast,
type size      size, day and
night mode, all of these things
require         require full
testing         testing
capability
capabilities to ensure
ensure the app is    is up to
the standards regarding
regarding driver
distraction
distraction.  Waze
distraction.
Waze
example of full app control.
Not all the apps
all the aps             all the
apps      apps are application
though        though.  We've
create        created a set of
templates           templates
that safe      safely offer
offer all the functional
functionalities in a
simple        simple,
predictable
predictable and safe manner
manner.  Here I would like
to give      give the example
of the
Audi      Audi sport concept
that is    is on demo      demo
as well.  You can see our Audi
Audi elegant
elegantly implemented
the API     API that they can
use to bring their       their
media Alfons Pfaller into cars.
The template          template
are working         working on
screen density         densities
and inputs and they are retion
retionly tested for
driver distraction.  And the
thing is    is all of the
of the application that are
already         already working
working with an drud
with Android Auto
Auto for your car screen
and for your phone screen, they
are working         working here
as well without extra work from
from our developer
developers.  And you
can see media braus
media browse        browse and
you can find your con tekt
tekt easily and safe
safely.
Messaging is    is one of the
of the major use cases in
the car.  For SMS but also
WhatsApp          WhatsApp or
Facebook          Facebook or
Allo, the integration is
integration with
auto is simple        simple and
based on Android
Android notification
notifications.  All
that is    is necessary is
is to integrate with our car
extend        extender object to
enable safe      safe, voice-
voice-centric
messaging           messaging
experience for users
users.  This is    is an example
of the        of the media
station.  Here you can see
WhatsApp          WhatsApp
notification showing
showing up.  Which is    is
working safe      safe and
predictable
predictable on a phone that is
is mounted         mounted on
the dashboard
dashboard of your car.
For WhatsApp          WhatsApp
you can meek
WhatsApp
you can make it work and that is
is working         working
for touch but also      also
focused-          focused-based
system.  Another way to
integrate with auto    Auto is
is through the Google
Assistant           Assistant.
Assistant-
Assistant-base ed   d apps
apps and services
services are inherent
inherently cross-platform
cross-platform and
their       their voice-
voice-centric
voice-centric nature makes them
them ideally
ideally suited for in-
in-car use.  The next present
presenter is    is
going to talk more about
about that so I will not explain
it in more detail        detail
here.       here.
So that'
So that's what we are working
working hard on to enable
in-     in-car system with
Android         Android.  We
work      work hard, an up-
up-to-        up-to-date and
secure platform
platform.  Now I would like to
welcome Chen      Chen on stage
to talk more about Google
Assistant           Assistant on
Android Auto      Auto.  Thank
you.
[ Applause ]
you, AJ    AJ.       AJ.  Hello
Hello, I'm Chen      Chen,
technical           technical
lead and manager         manager
on the Google Assistant
Assistant on Android
Auto      Auto team.  I'm
I'm here to tell you about
about how you the #2k68
#2k68ers can engage with users
in the car.  See if    if this
scenario sounds        sounds
familiar.  You're        You're
running         running late for
work and     and you rush out
the door.  On your drive you
think back to yourself
yourself, did     did I actually
actually lock the
front door?  Wouldn't
Wouldn't it be awesome
awesome if you could       could
talk to your car and say okay
Okay Google, did     did I
lock the door?  Or maybe on that
same commute you're
you're thinking
thinking, what meters
thinking,
what meeting         meetings am
I               meetings am I
am I actually
actually rushing         rushing
to or I better not forget
forget to buy milk before
I go home.  It would be great
if you could       could talk to
your car and say what's my next
meeting         meeting or
remind me to buy milk before I
go home.         home.  These
are all things        things
that the Google Assistant
Assistant can help you
with.  And more important
importantly, you as
the developer
developer can make your services
services available is
to
services available via     via
the assistant
assistant.            assistant.
As AG as mentioned before, voice
input is    is critical
critical in the car.
For safety reasons
reasons, we want to make sure
the users       users cape their
their eyes on the road
and hands on the wheel.  While
the users are on this journey
journey, we want to make
sure the user stays connected
connected.  They can
get things        things done,
and stay entertained.  The
Google Assistant
Assistant can provide that
intelligent
intelligent and conversational
voice as we move from      from
a mobile first to an AI first
world.  We want it to be the
ultimate copilot         copilot
for the user in the car.  Users
Users are spending
precious          precious time
in the car, and we're making
making the assistant
assistant help the
user complete the mission and
make the journey         journey
fun.      fun.
With the feature         feature
called my  My day   Day, you
can say okay Google, tell me
about       about my day.  And
the assistant         Assistant
will tell you about       about
upcoming          upcoming
calendar events, reminders,
commute traffic so you can hit
the ground running
running when you get to work.
On the road, your assistant
assistant can tell you
about       about traffic ahead
ahead or show you gas
stations          stations a, if
you need to make a pit stop.
stop.
If you're
If you're board you can ask
ask
If you're bored you can ask
ask the assistant
assistant to play that favorite
song      song you've download
downloaded or listen
listen to a variety of
music       music and pod koosts
and podcasts
podcasts.  We know that
staying         staying
connected is very
important           important
for users       users on the
road, so we make calling
calling and messaging
messaging easy with voice
actions like call mom, send a
kwhaes               send a
WhatsApp          WhatsApp
message or read my messages
messages.
Many of these experiences are
only possible because
because developer
developers like you have
implemented
implemented the right API
APIs.  So thank you for helping
us    us create        create
that great user experience.
experience.
Since the assistant is    is
cross-        cross-surface
cross-surface
cross-surface, it
will help the user get things
things done, whenever thr
whenever they are.
In the home and on the go.
Patrick
Patrick and AJ    AJ have talked
about       about messaging
messaging and media aps
and media apps
apps for integrating
integrating with auto
auto, the template
templated and notification
notifications apps
apps in AJ    AJ's pyramid
pyramid that want to
show a UI.  There are tons of
other aps     aps that don't
fall under these
category          categories.
How can you as a developer
developer get your
experience in the car without
having to deal with      with
the complexity
complexity of building
building a full automotive
automotive app and
having to accommodate different
screen size      sizes, various
inputs        inputs and out
puts      puts?
and out     outputting
outputs?
If
If your service can be
can be voice-
voice-centric
voice-centric in the car and you
want a lightweight      weight
integration
integration for reaching
reaching these users
users, then      then the
Google Assistant is    is a good
option.  How do you build for
the Google Assistant
Assistant?            Assistant?
Actions On Google is    is the
platform          platform for
developer           developers
to build for the Google
Assistant           Assistant.
The platform              The
platform          platform will
allow       allow developer
developers to reach
users wherever          wherever
the assistant is    is
available.  The platform
platform uses cloud
execution           execution so
users       users don't need to
pre-      pre-install any app
when they ask     ask for your
service by name, you'll be
connected           connected
immediate ly
immediately.  Many developer
developers are already
already building
building for Actions
On Google        Google.  When
building          building for
Actions On Google        Google,
there are     are three key
pieces that need to be defined
by the developer
developer.  Invocation
Invocation triggers
triggers, dialogs
triggers,
dialog        dialog, and
fulfillment
fulfillment.  Let me illustrate
with an example         example.
I like coding        coding
and I like fortune cookie
cookies.  So I want to build a
service that gives       gives
me a daily            me a daily
dose of coding
coding fortune
cookie        cookies.
cookies.
So the first step is    is I
needed        needed to find my
invocation            invocation
trigger         trigger.  How
does the user connect to my
service?            service?
What do         What do they
actually          actually have
to say?  In this case I'll make
it simple        simple,
whenever          whenever the
use     use arer says talking
talking coding
coding fortune cookie
cookie, then      then the
Google Assistant
Assistant will connect the user
to my service.
The next step is    is dialogs
dialogs.  So once the
user is    is connected
connected to my
service, how do I talk to them
them?  What kind of
information am I asking
asking and what kind of
responses           responses am
I      am I expecting
expecting?  What are valid
valid responses
responses and what are invalid
invalid responses
responses?  In this
case I'm     I'm going make it a
simple        simple question
do they want a Java      Java or
a C + +
them?  What kind of information
am I asking and what kind of
responses am I expecting?  What
are valid responses and what are
invalid responses?  In this
case I'm going make it a simple
question do they want a Java or
a C + + fortune cookie
cookie.  So there are only two
two valid       valid
responseness
responseness this case.  So
let's       let's suppose that
the user picked Java      Java.
We can move on to the third
step which is    is fulfillment
fulfillment.  For
fulfillment
fulfillment I have all the
information that I need, so how
do I go about       about
committing            committing
that transaction or computing
computing that action
on behalf of the
on behalf of
the use er        user so in
this case I'm     I'm going to
look      look in my bank of
Java      Java fortunes and I'm
I'm going to pick one out
for today       today.  Random
Random one.
Today
Today's for
Today's fortune says Codefucious
Codefucious says
for true happiness
happiness, prefer interfaces
over abstract          abstract
classes.  That's one I actually
actually use every day.
Actions On Google        Google.
The Google assistant
assistant and Actions On Google
Google are coming
coming to Android Auto
Auto and will open up a wide
possibility
possibility of use cases.
Agents and services that are
built       built on top of the
platform will transfer
transfer over.  If you think
that users       users will
interact with your agent or
service            or service in
the car, it's a good idea to
start thinking about       about
what is    is the user
experience that you want to
build for that special context.
One car-      car-specific
consideration is    is safety
safety and driver
distraction
distraction.  How can you build
a user experience that both
minimize          minimizes
driver distraction
distraction and alaw users
users to get things
things done and     and stay
entertained.
Let's
Let's think about potential
potential use cases
for engaging          engaging
with users       users in the
car.  What is    is possible
here?
One idea is    is reservations
reservations.  It's
a Friday        Friday night
and I'm     I'm meeting
meeting up with my husband
husband for dinner.  We
pick out a restaurant
restaurant and on the way there
I would love to be able to say,
book a table, and have that
table waiting for me by the time
I get there.  What would be
even      even more awesome
awesome and magical is
if    if the Google Assistant
Assistant and that
third-party
third-party service can suggest
a good reservation time that
takes       takes into account
my location          location,
traffic, and maybe parking
availability
availability.  So I make a make
a reservation for a time I can
definitely make.       make.
Another idea is    is food
ordering          ordering.  I'm
I'm working         working
late on a week night and I'm
too     too lazy to cook.  On my
way home I would love to be
able to put in an order at my
favorite restaurant
restaurant and have that food
delivered and arrived
arrived at my home by the time I
get there.  Saves       Saves
on time, saves       saves on
cooking         cooking.
earlier, how many      many
times have you driven
driven away from      from your
house and can't remember whether
you've actually locked
locked the front door?  It would
be very
very cool if you
could       could say okay
Google, check my door.  Or did
did I lock my door?  Just
lock it.     it.
Another one is lights
lights.  I'm driving
driving home and I actually
actually hate walking into
a dark house.  I'm     I'm
actually          actually
afraid of the dark.  It would be
great if from      from the car
I could       could say turn on
my living room lights
lights or turn on my dining
dining room lights
lights and     and I never have
to walk into a dark house
again.
Games
and entertainment
entertainment.  How many
many times have you been on long
road trips       trips with
kids      kids where you
struggle          struggle to
find a way to keep them
them entertained?  Wouldn't
Wouldn't it be awesome
awesome if you could
could say okay Google,
entertain my kids      kids and
have games that are     are age-
appropriate
age-appropriate for different
kids      kids so they can play
whatever they want.  They stay
entertained and I can focus on
the road.
road.
These are just some ideas
ideas on ways developer
developers can engage
with users       users in the
car.  I look      look forward
to what creative
creative ideas       ideas you
come up with.         with.
Please check out the Actions On
Google        Google site where
there are actually
actually code sample
samples and tools       tools to
help you build the dialog
dialog and triggers
triggers and fulfillment
steps       steps so that makes
makes it easier
easier to bring       bring up
your service.  We also      also
have demo      demos at the IoT
IoT     IoT and Android
Android domes.  We'll
actually          actually be
showcasing            showcasing
some of the        of the use
cases that I just talked about
including           including
controlling
controlling Hu    Hue lights
lights and August door
locks directly from      from
inside the car.  Thank you
you and back to pack trick.
[ Applause ]
PATRICK BRADY:  Thanks
Thanks, Chen      Chen.  It's
really exciting
exciting to see a new way for
developer           developers
to easily extend their
their services          services
into cars.  With conversational
voice powered         powered
by the Google Assistant
Assistant, we hope to
see many new types       types
of aps        of #57s         of
apps      apps in use cases.
You also      also heard from AJ
AJ how media and     and
messaging apsz
messaging apps      apps can
extend through the car in a
scale       scaleable way with
Android Auto      Auto templates
templates and
notification
notifications.  Google Assistant
Assistant and Android
Android so you can
worry about       about
building          building a
great app and experience for
your drivers.
This model       model has
helped Android Auto      Auto
grow to be the largest in-
in-car eco     ecosystem
today       today, and it
about       about to get a whole
lot bigger        bigger with
the Google Assistant
Assistant.  With      With 10x
growth        growth in users
users over the last
last year, and new partners
partners like Audi
Audi and Volvo       Volvo
building Android         Android
directly into their       their
cars, we know that developer
developers are going
to have plenty        plenty of
eager       eager drivers out
there who     who want to stay
connected           connected on
the road.  So we're excited to
continue this road ahead
ahead with all of you, to    to
build the future        future
of automotive
automotive infotainment and
criate a safe      safe and seam
less          seamless
experience for drivers
everywhere
everywhere.  Thanks
Thanks and enjoy       enjoy the
rest of the        of the show.
[ Applause ]
to build the future of
automotive infotainment and
criate a safe and seamless
experience for drivers
everywhere.  Thanks and enjoy
the rest of the show.
[ Applause ]
[Session ended
build the future of automotive
infotainment and criate a safe
and seamless experience for
drivers everywhere.  Thanks and
enjoy the rest of the show.
[ Applause ]
[Session concluded
concluded]
Thank you for joining
joining this session.  Brand
ambassador
ambassadors will assist
assist.  We'll be making
making room for those of you who
who have registered
registered for the
next session.  If you've
you've registered
registered for the next session
in this room, we ask     ask
that you please clear the room
and return via     via the
registration
registration outside.  Thank
you.
.
>>
Zun
>> Duncan do do af Alfons
Pfaller
app
Duncan Osborn Andre
Valente app dvrnlths.
AJ KIMBEMBE:
.
>>DUNCAN OSBORN:
AJ KIMBEMBE:  Blah blah
pretty blah blah blah.
AJ KIMBEMBE:  Blah blah blah
/PWHRA /PWHRA /PWHRA.
ANDRE VALENTE:  /PWHRA /PWHRA
/PWHRA gs
Google Search
Google Search I
mers I have
immersive
immersive rotten
rotten tomato        tomato s
tomatoes snippets care sell
ousel
carousel meat data
tadata
metadata cuisine
Nike
J son
SON
SPEAKER:
>>
Oo
SPEAKER:  Welcome
Welcome.  Please fill in the
seats near the front of
the        of the room.  Thank
you.
Welcome
Welcome.  Thank you for joining
joining.  Our session
will begin soon.
ANDRE VALENTE:
VALENTE:  Good afternoon
everyone          everyone.
Welcome         Welcome to our
session on stand out on Google
Search        Search with
structured data      data and
search.  My name is    is Andre
Valente and this is Duncan
Osborn        Osborn a product
manager         manager in
search.  Thanks        Thanks
for joining us today
today.
So the first thing       thing I
want to do is give      give a
little bit of perspective
perspective as to
how we arrived         arrived
at where we are by going a
little bit back to the evolution
evolution of search.
As you know Google's mission is
is to organize the world's
information and make it
accessible            accessible
and useful but how we are doing
this is    is changing
changing over
time.  Users are not satisfied
satisfied with us
us anymore a link to a possible
answer.  They want us    us to
provide the answers whenever
whenever possible and
help them      them navigate
through the space of possible
answers         answers, the
possible alternative
alternatives.  And in fact you
can see that many of our
products          products
including           including of
course the assistance
assistance are having
the steam       steam of gool
providing           providing
assistance            assistance
to our users.  So before and in
fact until now what you have if
you put a search like this
this to recipes is    is    is
a set of links that you can
explore, you can try out, and
you have some snippets
snippets to try to give
give you an idea of what is
is behind those links
behind those
links       links.  The users
users that land on their
land on your beige
on your page don't
have enough        enough
context and it's not clear their
their intent.  We tried
tried to make this better
and we launch        launched
the idea of Richards
of rich cards       cards.  The
idea is    is visual module
modules that organize
information about       about
what used      used to be a blue
link in wha        in something
that is    is simpler
simpler to read, easier
easier to navigate.  And these
cars were sometimes
sometimes organized
organized into carousel
carousels like you see here so
you can scroll        scroll
right       right or left to see
visual answers         answers
to your query       query.  And
now particularly in the last
last year or so we have
evolved even      even further
into this notion        notion
of immersive
immersives.  These are sort f
of mini applications
applications you
have where       where you can
explore a range of answers
answers.  Not only you
have the visual components
components but you
also      also have things
things like these step
targets         targets.  So you
can find your query       query
and say not only do I      do I
want a straw       strawberry
tart      tart recipe, I want
someone         someone that is
glut      gluten        gluten
free.  What happens heefr
What happens
however is    is in addition
addition to all the
information that Google has in
its knowledge engine
engine, what happens if    if we
use a lot of structure
structure third-party
structured data      data to
power this.  And what that means
is    is that there's
there's an opportunity
opportunity for you.
If          you.  If you have
a site where you have
information you can try to
organize and optimize
optimize its performance
performance in such
such a role that you can
participate in these features
features.  What we
have found is    is that the
sites       sites that implement
structured data      data
typically           typically
see increased click-
click-through-
click-through rates       rates
and increased
increased engagement
engagement.  In other words
words, the users
users that come to you     you
are better users       users.
So, for example here is    is
one use case that we found.
found.  Rotten
Rotten tomato        tomatoes
implemented structured data
data in more than 1 hundred
thousand
100,000 pages.  But the most
But the more important
the more
interesting
interesting part is    is these
pages resulted          resulted
in 25% % higher click-
click-through rate compared
compared with the rages
they have that didn't
didn't have structured data
data.  In other words
words, you can do some good
results         results for you.
Later       Later on we'll
have more case studies
studies that will explain the
details.  Now the remainder
remainder of this talk
we're going       going to teach
you how we can use structured
data      data to optimize
optimize
optimize your site's performance
performance.  We're
going to tell you how you can
use this to stand out, pick up
the right mark      markup, and
how     how to measure
measure the impact        impact
once you implement this.
this.
Now next Duncan is    is going
to talk to you about Google
Search        Search appears
appears and give      give
you more details.
>>DUNCAN OSBORN: Thavrnltion
OSBORN:
Thanks        Thanks, Andre
Andre.  Hi    Hi there,
I'm Duncan Osborn.  I'm a
product manager         manager
on search.           search.
So
So Andre is    is going to get
into how you implement and
measure structured data
data in just a second but tirs
second
second but first I thought
thought we would go
through the futures
futures so you can see how it
appears         appears to users
users and we will go
through the implementation
implementation
later       later.
So we have a broad set of
vertical          verticals
verticals that support
structured data      data in
them      them.  There are a
fairly large vertical
verticals and we have a good set
of partners          partners
at each one so there's
there's a good base to learn
from      from and we're
constant          constantly
thinking          thinking of
new vertical          vertical s
verticals.
So I chose just a couple of ways
to    to show off a
show off.  Let's       Let's get
started from      from recipes.
So this is    is a great
example         example of a
vertical          vertical where
we've invest        invested in
structured
invested
in structured data      data
features          features at
several levels        levels,
naming                levels,
namely        namely the page
level, the domain        domain
level and finally
finally the result level.  So
I'll walk through each one of
those.  It's dangerous to show
cookie        cookies at snack
snack time, but here we
go.  This is    is at page
level.  In this case we've taken
taken all the recipe leaf
results         results as we
kael            as we call them
them, which just means a
single recipe result and we
assemble them      them into a
single carousel
carousel at the top of the
of the page which makes
makes it easier
easier for users       users to
access all the recipes in one
single place and make their
their decision and finally
finally land on the one
they've         they've chosen
chosen.  You can see
here we're feature ing several
several different kinds
kinds of structured data
data.  We have the rating
rating, the calorie
county                calorie
count and the cook time.  All of
those are sourced directly from
from the mark-
mark-up on the third-party
third-party site.
It's also important
important to note that one click
away from      from this
experience is    is another
interface that we've even
even more heavily
heavily optimize
optimized for browse ing
browsing large numbers
numbers of recipes in
this case.  And here again we're
using       using the same
types       types of mark
markup but we've just
restructured them      them so
they fit better in the UX we've
cheesen         cheesen in this
case.  One of the things
important           important
we've seen several
we've seen
several         several visual
ramifications structure
structure here in terms
of rating        rating and
calorie         calorie count,
but what's behind this
experience is    is actually
actually the mark
markup at the page level which
tells us    us that it's a leaf
leaf result, a recipe page
so that allow       allows us
us to make decisions about
about how we then present
them      them to users
users.  So both kinds
kinds are important
important, the signal and how we
decorate that result for users
users.  So that's at page
level.
Now we move      move to domain
domain level.
level.  At this point we're
assembling            assembling
all the results         results
but the results that are
are in a single lifting
in a single listing
listing page of recipes
which comes from      from one
single page.  We now give
give the site owner       owner
a single property for their
their content
content.  So once again
again, we've all of the
of the content         content
you see here, just in a smaller
smaller card format
format.  A good example
example of how we're
fairly flexible
flexible in how we display
display this data
data.  But the other interesting
interesting point
here is    is that this list of
content is    is custom miizable
both in contents and order.
That gives       gives you a
very      very visible
visible level of    of control
over how your results
results appear        appear in
search, which is    is pretty
cool.
Okay.  That's domain
domain.  And finally
finally at the result level.  If
If we have a result that
rank      ranks, it's just a   a
single leaf      leaf page, we
won't          we won't just
leave it as a blue link, we'll
use any data      data we have
to decorate the results
results and also      also allow
allows users       users
to make decisions directly on
the search results
results page.       page.
And the next one I wanted to
show you, moving        moving
on from      from cookie
cookies to something to make you
even      even hungry
hungrier is restaurants
is restaurants
restaurants in SF,
which is    is what cool people
kal San Francisco
Francisco.  So in this case we
again have the domain
domain level results
results.  So    So we've taken
taken all the restaurants
that are     are in the listing
listing page and
assemble          assembled
them      them into a carousel
carousel.  But what's
interesting
interesting here in this case
the site owner       owner has
only just provided
provided the title       title
and we just shrink the card to
adapt to that kind of data
data.       data.
But
But in this case the site owner
owner can also      also
add things        things like
the cuisine         cuisine type
or the location for the
restaurant
restaurant.  So it's generally a
good idea to take a look
look at our developer
developer guidelines
guidelines to see what's
possible for a given data
data type and you can decide in
that case how you want us    us
to render        render the
cards       cards.  For example,
they could have also      also
added ratings         ratings
and those would appear
appear before the location and
the title       title.
title.
And then      then one other
point here when you're
you're doing domain
domain level mark      markup,
you're        you're only affect
ing           affecting your
results         results.  We
don't actually          actually
switch the results
results.
So to burn off the calorie
calories we're now
moving        moving to running
shoes       shoes and we're also
switching           switching
to a different product.  In this
case, imagine
case, image       image search.
So here I went to the image
image search tab and I
searched          searched for
Nike      Nike free
which is    is a shoe.  They're
They're exploring
exploring options
options and comparing
comparing how they
visually look      look.  But at
a certain point they want to
move to the #30i7b9
#30i7b9 where they make a
purchase.  There you need
additional            additional
information as a buyer and that
is    is where structured data
comes       comes in handy
handy.  So here in this case
we've included the price and the
rating        rating once I
tapped on the shoe I wanted to
buy.  And of course there's
there's the link at the
bottom of the page that allow
allows me to visit
visit and eventually
eventually purchase.
purchase.
Great.  Let's       Let's wrap
up these example
examples with a brand new
feature         feature that we
launch        launched just
about       about a week ago.
This is    is for events.  In
this case I searched
searched for concerts
concerts in NYC where I live,
and here at the top of the
of the page we have a
single box that assemble
assembles all of the
of the events for my
query       query.  So again
we've assemble
assembled things        things
but we rely on structured data
data to make this look
look good.  So much of the
data      data that we see here
here, the date, time,
location, and even      even the
image       image are provided
provided to us    us by
the site owner       owner.  So
this is    is again one of
these great features
features that we can provide to
users       users based on the
data      data that we're able
to share with publish
publishers.
Andre is    is here      here to
walk you through how to
implement all     all of this
mark      markup mvrnlths
markup.
ANDRE VALENTE:
VALENTE:  Thank you.  I'm
I'm going to walk you through
sort of the        of the
journey         journey of
implementing
implementing this on your site,
on your
property.  Before I do that, I
want to highlight
highlight and piggy       piggy
back on a couple of elements
elements of what is
strurt           is structured
data      data, what does it
look      look like.  Most
Most of you are developers
developers, but just
in case.  You see here on the
left side a specific card with a
helpspy and on the right side
I'm     I'm going to highlight
highlight a few
elements          elements so
you can see how they match.  You
can see this is    is a script
tag in JSON-       JSON-LD and
tit specifies
specifies this is    is a recipe
according to schema
schema and each of the        of
the property is    is going to
match components
components that can go into the
cards       cards.  In this case
this is    is a basic
quesadilla recipe becomes
becomes the title
title.  You see here as we
continue more tags, the imagine
gives       gives you
tags, image
tags, the image
image we're going to
display         display and the
description can give      give
you elements          elements
we can use in the smip      smip
use in the
snippet         snippet.
snippet.
This is    is how you would
specify         specify an
aggregate and translate the
information to the stars
stars and the number of review
reviews that you see on
the left.  And then      then
timely, you here have the total
time, the cooking
cooking time the 10 minutes as
well as the number of calorie
calories.  So the lesson
learned hoor is    is
learned here is    is
each specific mark      markup,
in this case each recipe is
is going to have its own
specification and you can see
how they translate into the
elements of the        of the
card.  This is    is sort of the
overall         overall journey
of the        of the
implementation
implementation process and we're
going to walk you through each
element of it.  The first one
you want to identify
identify the best      best mark
mark      markup match.
Throughout            Throughout
this journey         journey I
will talk about       about
different tools       tools and
here's a summary
summary.  There's
There's the search gallery, the
structured data      data
testing         testing tool and
the search console
console are available to you
you.  Hopefully
Hopefully you can take a moment
and try those out     out after
we talk.
The first starting
starting point is    is the
search gallery.  It basically
basically allow
allows you to figure out what
are the closest way you can add
structured data      data and
the kind of things        things
that you can do.  The first
party       party want to
highlight           highlight on
the left top, this is    is a
brand new version of the
of the search gallery that's
been published
published this week.  You see
these enhancements
enhancements and these are
things        things that you
can do more or less dependent
dependent on the kind
of information you have.  If you
have recipes on your site, but
these rs things        things
that can enhance your results
enhance
your results         results in
Google Search        Search
independently
independently on what you do.
For instance          instance
you can improve how the bread
crumbs        crumbs are
structured
structured, corporate
corporate contacts logos
logos.
Once you look      look at these
opportunities
opportunities, low-
low-hanging fruits
fruits, probably everyone
everyone can do that.
And then      then you see the
second part      part, the
vertical          vertical
content types       types that
Duncan        Duncan was
describe ing
describing to.  You have data
You have events,
pod evidence
events,
podcasts          podcasts, so
this is    is the documentation
documentation for
recipes and you see there is
several kinds       kinds of
mark      markup I can have.  On
the left side it's like a
single recipe or a single query
query and on the top
extreme right we see a list.  So
list.  So Duncan
Duncan was talking
about       about how you can
make a list page.  This is    is
how it would look      look
like.  Look             like.
Look
Look carefully
carefully at the specification
here.  This is    is all on the
Google website         website
and towards the bottom we always
show you the property.  Early
Early on I was talking
about       about the schema
schema.  Here we kind of
give      give you a summary of
the things        things we
expect and it takes       takes
special care to look      look
look at which things
things are required
required.  If you don't have all
the required elements
elements, they won't
they won't actually
actually be pushed
actually be
published           published.
And of course it's a good idea
for you to put the recommended
fields        fields as well
because         because that
will increase the quality of the
of the result, the
quality of the card that we
could       could show and we
make you look      look better.
So like number of calorie
calories in a recipe,
the information would be added
as Duncan describe
described.
Once you identify
identify the kind of mark
markup you want to have, the
incomes         incomes step is
is to actually
to act --        act -- next
step is    is to actually
actually draft it and
play with it.  Back to the page
of the        of the
documentation is    is you see
these these links with a C mark-
mark-up.  For each of
these we give      give you a
skample               you a
sample        sample of what the
mark-       mark-up is    is
for that kind of structural data
data.  And that will bring
you     you to the second tool
.
It opens       opens with a
sample        sample of that
specific kind of page so you can
use it as a starting
starting point.  The idea is
is you can kind of play with it,
see what it look      looks
like.  Generally try to make it
complete so it has all the
components
components.  And you can use
this to as sort of a starting
starting point.  We
recommend to you     you that
you create        create a
version of a sample
sample page.  I'll take a page
of your site, for instance
instance, that has a
recipe or something, and then
then add the mark
markups to that and test it out.
So you can actually give
give the address of the
of the page, an SDTT will go
pick up that page, analyze it
and tell you what happened
happened with it and
give      give you whatever
warning         warnings might
exist       exist.  If    If
you're           If you aren't
aren't ready       ready
to publish yet     yet, you can
cut and paste       paste and
still test it.  It's just a
little more cumbersome
cumbersome.
Once your page verify
verifies, your next step is
is    is to see how it look
looks like.  You have this
preview         preview function
here.  Once you click preview
preview you see a simple
simple card.  It depends
how much information
information you
display         display you can
see what your elements
elements will look      look
like in realistic card that
would be shown       shown in
search.  And that helps you also
tweak       tweak your context.
Maybe try different pictures
or see what's the best      best
way to show      showcase your
structured data      data.  So
at this point we understand
understand what we
want to do.  We tested one to
see what it looks like.  And now
the next step is    is to
deploy        deploy this for
some pages       pages or.  We
generally recommend you don't do
this for everything at once.
Get a subset of your site --
site -- actually
actually can you go one
page back?  That you use a
subset of your site and use that
to try out.
So add this to just perhaps
--            perhaps -- just to
get a notion        notion of
what it would look      look
like.
Now
Now, more technical
technical.  So there's
there's actually two     two
ways in which you can add the
structured data      data.  One
is    is the script I showed
showed you earlier
earlier in Json-
Json-LD you can put in a script
tag and it's actually
actually the most      most
common way.  And the other one
is    is you can use micro daust
daust like this.
use
micro data      data like this.
manually          manually but
that's not a great idea.  What
you would like to do is    is
use your CMS.  I imagine most
most of you who     who have
large or size      sizeable or
not large, have a management
management system to
manage your content
content.  But you want to the
most      most common way we
have found people do it is    is
that they pick up a suitable
structured data      data CMS
plug      plugin.  There's
There's many CMS's that
have plug-       plug-ins that
you can get.  The idea is    is
we published              we
publish         publish your
content         content but it
then      then publish
publishes the structured data
data with it so you don't
have to manage things
things one by one.      one.
So once you     you put this in
a specific subset of your site,
it's time for you to review
review        review the
stats and for that we get to a
third tool which is    is the
search console         console.
console.
Search console is    is similar
to Google analytics
analytics but it focuses on
Google Search        Search.  It
tells       tells you how
search looks at your      your
site and what elements
elements appear        appear
and how many      many times it
appears
appears, et cetera.  Different
from      from the structure
data testing         testing,
the console         console has
has a   a little bit of set
up because         because you
have to sign up    up and verify
properties
properties.  How many      many
of you     you have verify
verified or used
used search console
console to get an idea?  Not as
many.  Maybe a third or a fourd
third or a
fourth        fourth.  So I'll
give      give you a little bit
of detail        detail and
there's         there's more to
it than      than that.  The
first step for you is    is to
get associated with an account.
So you have anybody
anybody can get an account on
search console         console
but then      then what you have
is    is the verification
process that provides
provides you have rights
rights to the site that you want
to test or use on search
console         console, much
much like Google analytics
is    is the same process.
Commonly          Commonly you
do this by uploading
uploading some special file to
your site or perhaps
perhaps to the main one of the
of the components
components of your
domain        domain name
provider          provider.
provider.
Now
Now you might want to, if you
have a large organization, you
might want to check, it's
frequently            frequently
the case that somebody
somebody else might have used
used and set it up and in
this case they can authorize
authorize you and it
makes       makes life a slilt
life a little simple
simpler.  Once you
register          register the
ability         ability to
manage your site through search
console         console you want
to add site maps      maps.
And site maps      maps are a
way for us    us to look
look and see what information
you have.  Of course we already
look      look at site maps if
if they're         they're
vulnerable            vulnerable
but this helps.  For instance
instance, imaging
imaging display
display some new stuff, you use
that to figure out what
what the components
components are of your site.
You can do this for a section of
your site while you figure
things        things out.
This is    is what search
console looks like.  Much
Much like Google analytics
analytics.  There's
There's a lot of stuff
here.  Different reports
reports and it's not always
very      very easy to find.
But let me walk you through some
ways in which you can dig into
the data      data for your
implementation
implementation.  First
use the rich cards       cards
report and that monitor
monitors which elements
monitors
steward data elements
elements were correctly
correctly found on
your pages after a crawl
crawl.  And the first thing
thing you want to do is look
look at issues were found.
The structured data      data
testing         testing allow
allowed you to test one
one specific mark      mark
up.  Looks at what elements
elements are on your site
and what do         what do
they look      look like.
Keeping         Keeping in mind
it takes       takes a while to
crawl       crawl your site.
You might want to leave a couple
of days to catch up to this.
What you want to do is    is to
look      look at all the
critical          critical
issues, remember those sort of
obligatory            obligatory
or necessary properties
properties.  So for
instance          instance you
may want to look      look at
those because         because
those things        things may
actually          actually
prevent those from showing
structured data      data into a
card.
Let's              card.
Let's look      look at the
issues that were affecting
affecting the type.  See
below the           below the
specific site both recipes.  If
recipes.  If you
click       click on recipe you
get a subset of a report and you
can see there's         there's
218 invalid cards       cards
and in the bottom you see the
problems          problems that
were found.  These were a very
very good idea of what it is
that you need to fix.  As you
see in this case there's
there's a bunch of
opportunities
opportunities that you might
have missed in terms of adding
adding nutrition.  But
the most important is    is
there's         there's 218
pages in fact all of the
of the ones because
because they seem to be missing
missing a field in this
case, imagine.  If
case, image       image.
If you click on    on that same
line, you can dig even deep
deeper and find example
examples.  Search console can
guide you to specific pages on
your site where that problem was
found.  In addition
addition if you click on one of
those further, you can actually
actually get a dialog
dialog that may
eventually            eventually
leave you to the            you
to figure out exactly
exactly where that went wrong.
To try to help you develop this
at a relatively
relatively fine grain
grain level.  For instance
instance in this case you
see on the left side you're
you're missing
missing, on the right side
you'll see marked in blue on the
list of ischemia             of
schema        schema, the
property was not dpild
dpild and it's obligatory
obligatory.  Try to
sort of connect the lowest
lowest level of the
of the specific page to do
implementation
implementation of your site.
So now you want to fix and
launch index
index.  Keep in mind it
could       could take days to
get to all of it.  Now you're
you're ready       ready
and you publish         publish
the stuff, the question for you
the most important
important one is    is how do I
know my return on investment
investment.  How do I
know this was useful and how do
I know what the results
results are in terms of the
effort        effort that I put
in    in.
So these are           these are
some of the        of the key
stats.  Certain things
things for web pages, clicks,
impressions,
impressions, the number of times
the information was shown,
click through rate, average
positioning
and you can get out of this
through t   the search analytics
analytics report.
And sich analytic
analytics report        report
gives       gives information
how each part of the
part of the site did     did.
And in fact it also      also
can help you do both with and
without the mark      markup
which is    is a great way for
you to compare and one of the
of the way s       ways
was used      used to figure out
what happened
happened.  So view impressions
impressions, clicks
clicks, as we discuss
discussed before and you
can filter        filter based
on search feature
feature type.  So a rich
rich and non-      non-rich
result depending
depending on the context.  And
you want to try to analyze that
have the high CTR     CTR.  You
can         You can use this to
detect what is    is working
working well.  What is
well.  What are
the places where your
implementation
implementation have the best
results         results.
results.
The search appearance filter
filter in which case you
can select the results
results that have structured
data      data.  You can also
also filter        filter
based on a pattern
pattern, so perhaps
maybe it's under a specific
folder        folder or a
specific UR    URL pattern
pattern         pattern
you can specify         specify
this here and     and compare
how it looks compared
compared to the rest of the
of the site.  You can also
look      look at date ranges
which can be used      used if
you implemented
implemented this one week and
the following week      week you
can compare like before and
after.
This is    is an roefr
is an overview of
process among structured daert
structured data
data and now Duncan is
is going to tell a little more
about       about the sites
sites that have implemented
implemented what
kind of R   ROI do they get.
>>DUNCAN OSBORN: Thanks
Thanks.  Okay.  Final stretch.
I'm
I'm going to walk you through
partners          partners
across several         several
different vertical
vertical s            verticals
to show the diversity
diversity of success we've seen
so far.  Let's       Let's start
with the one that you just saw.
Rotten        Rotten tomato
tomatoes.  Again, a good
adoption          adoption of
structured data      data which
led to        led to a 25% %
higher click-
click-through rate for those
results         results.  But
they went to one, here we saw
food.com          food.com.
They also      also had good
kovrnltion            kovrnltion
of structured data
had good dovrnlg
had good
govrnlg                  had
good coverage of structured data
data with 80% % and they
saw a 35% % increase of CTR
CTR which is    is super
encouraging
encouraging.
Next going over to Europe
Europe, in this case local
restaurant            restaurant
listing         listings.  A
mark-       mark-up on 90% % and
they saw a fairly high increase
in CTR        in CTR.  Moving
Moving back to recipes
but over to Japan       Japan.
So here is            So here
this is    is an interesting
interesting case
because         because not only
did     did they see an
increase in interaction on those
results         results, but
the resulting
resulting session as users
users landed        landed on
those pages was of higher
quality.  So if    if you're
you're in one of those
vertical          verticals it
depends on the quality of the
of the user landing
landing on those pages.  This
is    is a great sign.
And finally         finally
moving        moving to South
America         America
America 82% % higher CTR
CTRs.  This is    is super
encouraging
encouraging.  And hopefully
hopefully we'll see
some of you on this list next
talk.
So we covered         covered
three things        things in
in this talk.         talk.
The first is    is the
opportunity
opportunity which is    is
literally           literally to
stand out on search
search.  One of the        of
the rare opportunities
opportunities you
have to customize
customize your results
results visually for Google
users       users.  And we have
quite a few vertical
verticals for now and we're
constant          constantly
thinking          thinking of
new vertical          verticals.
So if you're           if
you're not on the list that I
showed        showed before,
stay tuned       tuned.
Senld               tuned.
Second, we show you the tools
tools that you can use to
implement all of that structured
data      data and to measure
measure the impact
impact and of course the
results         results as we've
seen can be very      very
promising           promising.
So just to wrap up, this is
is a quick reminder of the
of the links that can
hopefully           hopefully
help you get started if you
haven't already         already.
The search gallery to see what
the options         options
are.  It's good to click through
the content         content
that corresponds to the content
content you have on your
site.  Second, one you start to
implement structured data
data, the testing
testing tool is    is there to
diagnose and indicate any
rear          any error
errors you have in your mark
markup and guide you
through the correct practices to
make sure it's working
working properly
properly.  And finally
finally in search console, once
you manage        manage to ship
all of your structured data
data you can enjoy
enjoy your results
results with the analytics
analytics contained
therein         therein.
And that's about #i9
about it.  There are search
office hours       hours for any
questions you may have.  Please
take advantage of that.  And
otherwise           otherwise,
please enjoy       enjoy the
rest      rest of IO    IO.
Thank you very much much
very much
much.
[ Applause ]
And that's about it.  There are
search office hours for any
questions you may have.  Please
take advantage of that.  And
otherwise, please enjoy the rest
of IO.  Thank you very much.
[ Applause ].
>>
Please fill in the seats near
the front of the        of the
room.  Thank you.
SPEAKER:  Good afternoon
everyone          everyone.  I'm
Gerardo Capiel        Capiel
and I lead product management
management for
consumer payment products
products here at
Google.  And with me is    is my
partner         partner in
crime, Varouj Chitilian who is
is the engineering
engineering side.
Payments
Payments are at the heart of
commerce          commerce.  If
If I want to buy a cup of
coffee        coffee, I've got
to pay for it.  Payments
Payments are that link
between desire and fulfillment
fulfillment.  And
that link is    is paramount
paramount to making
making your apps
apps grow and your businesses
thrive        thrive.
Unfortunately that link is also
also a major pain point
for many of you.  Particularly
on the mobile web, where
conversion rates       rates are
a third of what they are on
desk      desktop.  We're
constant          constantly
thinking about       about how
to make payments
payments easier        easier,
faster        faster, and safe
safer.
Today we're going
we're going to be talking to you
about       about the
foundation that we built
built with Android
Android pay   Pay, and about
about how we're expanding
expanding our API
APIs to enable richer commerce
commerce experiences,
both online and in store.  He ta
it away
store.  Take it away      away.
CHITILIAN:  The foundation as
Gerardo         Gerardo
mentioned is Android
Android pay.  Our solution
solution for fast
fast and secure mobile paements
secure
mobile payments
payments.  Over the past
past year, the team has been
working         working around
the clock to scale
clock to expand
expand this foung gloek
gloekly               foung
globally and I'm     I'm praud
to say that Android
Android Pay is    is available
in 10 markets         markets.
But we're not stopping
stopping there.  In the coming
coming months we'll
we'll be launching
launching in Brazil
Brazil, Canada, Russia
Russia, Spain       Spain and
Taiwan.           Taiwan.  So
the momentum is    is
incredible.
[ Applause ]
I'm
I'm personally very      very
excited about       about Brazil
Brazil, because
because it will be         will
be the first Latin American
country and I really want to
visit       visit there.
there.
We're not just strengthening
strengthening the
foundation by expanding
expanding it.  We're
strengthing
strengthing it also through
partnership
partnerships.  One example
example of this is    is
a push provisioning poi
provisioning API
APIs.  These API     APIs
allow       allow issuers
issuers to em    embed
core functionalities into their
their own apps      apps.
For example in this case a
discover app user can click the
link      link, this will
provision their       their card
to this device and they can go
into the score, tap and pay to
purchase a good, without ever
having instaud
having installed
installed the Android
Android pay app.  There's
There's been phenomenal
phenomenal success
and we're really proud of this
API     API.      API.
We're also      also strengthen
ing               strengthening
this foundation by partnering
partnering with app
developer           developers.
We're doing this through the
Android         Android Pan
Pay in-     in-app poi
in-app API     APIs that
thousand          thousands of
apps      apps have integrated
integrated with.
They are bringing seamless
seamless, stream lined
strooth               lined
smooth        smooth check
checkout.  For example the
jet.com app has seen      seen a
3.5X conversion
conversion rate increase just by
implementing
implementing these in-
in-app API     APIs in their
their check       checkout
flow.       flow.
We're also expanding
expanding this foundation to the
mobile web and we're bringing
Android         Android Pay
Pay to the mobile web.  And
we're bringing          bringing
it to the API request
requests in chrome      Chrome.
So we're very      very excited
about       about that.  And
recently Washington
Washington post
instituted
instituted these API     APIs
and we've seen a
APIs.  We're very
very excited about       about
all the momentum
momentum we're seeing
seeing in building
building this foundation that we
have built       built over the
past      past year.
year.
Now I would like to pass it over
to Gerardo         Gerardo so
he can talk about       about
how we're building
building on top of this
foundation that we have, so we
can expose our users to even
even greater mobile payment
payment experiences.
GERARDO CAPIEL:  Thanks
Thanks, Varouj        Varouj.
Great.  So let's       let's
start with online.  As many of
you know rges               you
know, having a stream lined
stream
streamlined check       checkout
experience is    is critical
critical for your
websites          websites to
grow and for your business to
thrive        thrive.  We want
to make it easier        easier
for you to make it easier
easier for your      your users
users to transact
transact online and not
have to deal with on    onerous
forms       forms.  And we're
going to do that two     two
ways.         ways.  First,
we're collaborating
collaborating with
the a major payment platform
platforms.  Last
Last year we announced
announced initiative
initiatives with visa      visa
and master      MasterCard
MasterCard.  And as
you might have heard in Sr
in Sridhar            in
Sridhar's key neat earlier
in
Sridhar's key note earlier
earlier, we're adding
adding pay pal to that
list.  As we role out those
integration
integrations, users will be
will be able to link
either visa      visa check
checkout, master pass or
pay pal to their Android
Android pay account and they
will enjoy       enjoy a stream
streamlined
authentication
authentication and payment
payment experience.  And
the best      best part is
is they don't have to do any
additional            additional
work.  If    If they're already
already accepting
accepting visa    Visa
check       checkout, master
Master pass    Pass or pay
pal.
So let's       let's take a look
look at how that works
works.        works.
We flip the phone, please?  All
right       right.
So it's starting
starting to get hot out there
already         already.  Summer
is    is around the corner
corner.  And I'm     I'm
starting          starting to
think about       about it's
time to spend some time around
the pool      pool.  So what do
what do I like to have
around the pool      pool?
Well, marg Rita      Ritas,
that's for sure.  So earlier
today       today I went and
started looking         looking
around for some m            for
some Ma
around for some margar
margarita           margarita
mix and I have some in my
shopping          shopping cart.
Williams Sonoma        Sonoma,
great e-commerce
e-commerce site.  I think I have
enough margarita economics
economics and I'm
I'm ready       ready to check
out.  Now I see a visa    Visa
check       checkout button.
When I click that      that
button, voila       voila I see
my visa cards already
already.  I didn't          I
didn't have to enter in my user
name or my pass      pass
password.  It's that simple
simple.  And the best
best part is    is to finish
finish, I just apply
apply my fingerprint, and
voila       voila again, I'm
I'm done.  Just a really
fantastic           fantastic
experience.  And like I said,
the best      best      best
part is    is, that
that Williams Sonoma
already         already has visa
visa check did you
visa check
checkout, so when we real
out the integration
integration, they'll
they'll be ready       ready to
go.  Nothing else to do.
But we're not stepping
we're not
stopping          stopping
there.  As you probably
probably heard earlier today
today, our users
users have saved       saved
hundreds of millions of payment
payment instruments to
their       their Google
account.  And they do that when
they're         they're making
making purchases on Google
play, on YouTube
YouTube, or transacting
transacting in
Chrome        Chrome.  And the
benefit of that is    is that
they get a simplified
simplified check       checkout
experience on future purchases.
It's really great experience.
So what if we could       could
bring that simplified
simplified check
checkout experience to
your apps and the website
websites that you built
built.  Well, as hopefully
hopefully you heard
in the earlier         earlier
key #2k9
earlier key     keynote, today
today we announced
announced the Google
payment API     API.  And when
you implement that API     API,
your customers will be
will be able to quickly
quickly check out using
using any of the cards
cards in their       their
Google account.  Just super
simple        simple.  And
that's going to work, as I said,
in apps      apps, on the web,
and as you'll see in a bit, the
assistant           assistant.
So let's       let's take a look
look at that.
I'm
I'm going to pop over here.
Rand let's
over      over here.
And I'm     I'm going to fire up
one of my favorite apps, the
wish app.  And wish has been
testing         testing this API
API with us    us over the
last      last couple of months.
And so I was talking about
about summer.  The pool
pool, I need some pool
pool toys.  I love this
inflatable lounge
lounger.  But unfortunately last
last year I jump
jumped off the diving board,
belly flopped on to the lounge
lounger and popped it so I
need another one.  Fraef
one.
So I have it in my shopping
shopping cart already
already ready
ready to go.  And if    if I see
at the bottom of the screen
there is a pay with Google
button.  When I click that
button, I see one of the last
last card that I used
used, but if    if I click
further, I can see all the cards
cards in my Google
account, including
including those that I added
through an
added through Android
Android pay   Pay.  Hit
continue, and voila       voila
again, transaction is    is
complete.
[ Applause ]
.  Hit continue, and voila
again, transaction is complete.
It's really fantastic
fantastic.  Super simple
simple.  Love it.
So in the next few months we're
going to be piloting
piloting the Google payment API
API with a number of
leading merchants
merchants and apps      apps,
and we want all of you to be
able to pilot       pilot this
app and implement
implement it and to accelerate
that process, we're partnering
partnering with
leading payment         payment
processor           processor s
s such      such as brain
braintree and stripe and
V
and first data      data and
world pay.  We're really excited
to see what you all do with the
API and what fantastic
fantastic conversion
rates       rates you get.  Soon
we're going to be uploading
uploading our
developer           developer
documentation
documentation, and in the
meantime          meantime I
encourage you all to go to
developer
developers.Google
Google.com/payments
and register to get notification
notification of
when the developer
developer documentation is    is
available so you can get going.
going.
Now as I've mentioned, this also
works       works on websites
websites.  So tomorrow
morning I would encourage you
all to go get a cup of coffee
coffee, free on us    us.
You don't have to pay for I
and go to the future of web
payment         payment session
on stage 6 at 8:       at 8:
8:30 a.m.  But if you can't get
up that early       early, and
I'll be up that early
early.  I'll be there.  We have
office hours
at 9:    9:30 a.m. tomorrow and
Friday        Friday at 11:
11:30 a.m.  Hope to see you all
there.        there.
So now that yeef
now that you've seen how easy it
is to do the transactions
transactions on the
web and in app sz,            in
app s       apps, let's
let's talk about       about how
seamless          seamless the
transactions can be        can
be in the the assistant
assistant.  I hope a
lot of you here in the crowd own
a Google home, and if you do,
you've hopefully
hopefully had the opportunity
opportunity to buy
every       everyday essentials
from      from over 50 merchants
merchants, including
including whole foods
foods and Walgreens
Walgreens.  Soon we're
going to be adding even
even more merchants who     who
have integrated
integrated with      with our
Google shopping API     APIs.
But
But we're taking        taking
it one step further.  We're also
also going to enable you
all to build purchase actions.
purchase
actions with the assistant
assistant.  And in case
you didn't        didn't see it
it, at the last session,
here's how it works       works.
So the user simply says I want
to talk to Pan        to Panera
to Panera.  They
specify         specify what
they want to order.  Panera
Panera might even
even suggest some drinks
drinks that they might want to
go with that order.  And then
then the user is    is able
to complete the transaction
using       using the cards
cards in their       their
Google account and authenticate
with their finger        finger
print.  That simple
simple.  Fantastic
Fantastic experience.
So now you see how we're making
making the assistant an
even      even greater platform
platform for commerce
skrvrnlths
commerce
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:  Wow     Wow,
Gerardo         Gerardo that was
super cool.  How about
about we use the assistant
assistant to order some
Panera        Panera for after
after this session?
GERARDO CAPIEL:
CAPIEL:  Okay.  But let me pay
you back for dinner.  I don't
want it to be just on you.  And
what I can do is    is I'll send
you some money using
using our new Gmail       Gmail
sent money function.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:  Everyone
Everyone has seen
seen that feature
feature before.
before.  How about       about
you pay and I'll show the
audience          audience
something really koog
something
really cool that no one has soon
before?  Who     Who wants to
see     see something super
cool?
[ Applause ] come on, let's
How about you pay and I'll
show the audience something
really cool that no one has soon
before?  Who wants to see
something super cool?
[ Applause ]
Let's
Let's move to cast 1.  There you
go.
Okay Google.  Send 10
dollars            $10 to
Gerardo            to Gerardo
for dinner.
dinner.
Yes.
go.
Okay Google.  Send $10 to
Gerardo for dinner.
Yes.
[ Applause ]
Gerardo
Gerardo awesome
GERARDO CAPIEL:
CAPIEL:  Awesome
Awesome.
I think
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
CHITILIAN:  I think you have to
go back a slide.  Let's
Let's go back two slides
slides?
GERARDO CAPIEL:
CAPIEL:  So, thank you.
As you saw we're adding P2P to
the assistant
assistant.  And it will leverage
leverage the debit
cards       cards in your Google
account to send money to
friends and oertion r others
others.  And we're just getting
started.  We plan to soon on
soon on-     on-board
other P2P provider
providers.  Vurge        .
Varouj        Varouj?  Jvrnlths
?
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
CHITILIAN:  So Gerardo
Gerardo has shown some really
cool stuff we're working
working on in mobile payments
payments in the online
space.  We all know that 85% %
of commerce          commerce
still happens in stores
stores.  So I would like to talk
to you     you a bit about
about how we're enhancing
enhancing our
merchant-
merchant-facing API     APIs to
give      give your customers
customers
customers a better in-
in-store experience.
experience.
At the center        center of
it all is loyalty
loyalty.  Loyalty is    is a
connection between you, the
merchant, and your customers.
customers.  The
user.  And we would like to help
you with loyalty
loyalty in three ways.  We would
like to help you one, with
enrollment
enrollment.  So helping exposure
loyalty programs to Android
Android pay   Pay users
users and signing them
them up.
Two
Two, with engagement
with engagement
engagement.  Once the
Android         Android pay
Pay user has your loyalty
loyalty card associated
in their account, being
being able to
push to them that are     are
relevant to them      them.  And
three we would like to help you
with easy redemption
redemption and earning
earning of loyalty points
points and offer       offers.
So that just with a simple
simple NFC tap, what we
call a smart tap, the user with
Android         Android pay can
transmit loyalty         loyalty
and offer       offer
information just as easily as
they paid today       today with
Android         Android Pay
Pay.  So let's look      look
at each of these three
individually
individually.
Android Pay     Pay
user.  And I need to go to
Walgreens           Walgreens to
pick up some shampoo
shampoo.  It's for my daughter
daughter, of course.
[ Laughter ]
Pay will send the following
notification
notification.  It says fast
faster check       checkout at
Walgreens           Walgreens.
Add your balance for an easier
easier way to save.
Balance rewards is    is a
loyalty         loyalty program
for Walgreens
Walgreens and Walgreens
Walgreens has
implemented
implemented our smart tap
technology at their payment
payment terminals.  So
with one tap on this
notification
notification and a few things
things in the Android
Android pay 57
Android pay app,
we can easily sign up the
Android         Android pay user
for the rewards         rewards
program.  So super exciting
exciting.  But we ever
ever taken       taken it
a step further.
Say I'm     I'm a balance
rewards         rewards member
and I'm     I'm an Android
Android pay user.  But
you haven't             you
haven't connected
connected my balance rewards
rewards card to my an
Android         Android pay.  So
let's       let's move to the
demo      demo.
The second cast.
There we go.  Great.
Let me try some magic here.
There uh-uh   -uh
There you go.  These are demo
slides        slides, I guess.
Perfect         Perfect.
So we're on cast 2 now.  So now
I'm buying        buying a bag
of nuts and I have to remember
my phone number here.
I it was a land line that I had
four years       years ago.
Now I tap
so now I've tapped the pay but
I've entered my information
manually          manually.
Wouldn't          Wouldn't it be
magical if    if I was somehow
somehow told that I can
somehow         somehow add this
balance rewards         rewards
card that I have entered
entered into Android
Android automatically
automatically.
Wow     Wow, that's pretty cool.
We just got notification from
from an Android
Android pay.  And with a single
click in the app, we can now
save this balance rewards
rewards card that I used
used manually
manually into an Android pay so
some subsequent visits
so on
subsequent visits        visits
I don't have to punch in my
phone number and remember what
it was years       years ago.
ago.
So second pillar        pillar
of loyalty         loyalty and
the second area      area we
would like to help you with is
is engagement
engagement.  How do you engage
with that customer
customer that saved       saved
your loyalty         loyalty
card in Android         Android
pay and push them      them off
so they'll         they'll come
back to your store?
For this we have another demo
demo      demo with the
Panera        Panera
Panera app.  It's called the my
Panera        Panera program.
I'm     I'm going to go into the
Panera        Panera app and
I'm     I'm going to click on
awards        awards.
What I'll do is    is I'll save
my my  My Panera        Panera
card to an drad            to
Android         Android by
Android pay by one
click of this button.  Great.
Great.  Some my Panera
loyalty         loyalty card is
is now saved       saved to
an drad      drad pay.  Now if I
go into Android         Android
pay, I see the my Panera
loyalty         loyalty card
which is    is really cool.  But
when I click       click into
it,
when I click into it we'll
actually          actually see a
rich set of offer       offer s
offers associated with
my my  My Panera        Panera
card that you would have
have seen if    if the casting
casting worked that I
was looking         looking at.
What's even      even cooler is
if I'm     I'm walking by a
Panera        Panera, I will
actually          actually get a
g     a geo       a geo
notification
notification that tells
tells me I have offer
offers available to be redeemed
redeemed at the Panera
story       story.
Panera store.  This
is    is a great way in which
to engage your customers
customers after
they've         they've linked
their loyalty         loyalty
program
you guys can take a look
look at them      them at
developer
developers.Google.com/payments
the last
feature         feature we
would like to help you with.
And that's to redeem loyalty
loyalty.  And offer
offers at the story
story.        story.
at the store.
I mentioned about smartd
about       about stab
about smart tab.
We're happy to announce smart
tap will be         will be
available to businesses
businesses of all
size sz         sizes including
small and medium size      sized
businesses
businesses.  And in order to do
that, we have partner
partnered with dloefr
partnered
with clover, a first data
company         company.
The clover terminals now
now support smart tap
technologies to allow
allow for he'sy       he'sy
redemption
redemption.  I would
redemption.  I
would like to invite the CEO of
of    of clover come up
>> Thanks Thanks, Varouj
Varouj.  We are huge
huge fans of what Varouj
Varouj and Gerardo
Gerardo are doing here
to really push the boundary
boundaries in commerce
commerce and consumer
consumer experiences in
commerce          commerce.  So
let's give      give these guys
a hand.
[ Applause ]
and
Gerardo are doing here to
really push the boundaries in
commerce and consumer
experiences in commerce.  So
let's give these guys a hand.
[ Applause ]
Clover's mission is    is to
enable innovation
innovation in commerce
commerce on the merchant side.
We do this in two        in two
ways.  We provide open platform
platform s
platforms in point-
point-of-sale
point-of-sale and payments
payments to developer
developers and also
also through our parent
company         company first
data      data, one of the
of the world's leading
payments          payments
technology companies, we provide
broad distribution capabilities
capabilities to
our vast      vast away
away of merchants
merchants both in the U.S. and
in many countries
countries worldwide
worldwide.  Now, we'll be
supporting            supporting
smart tap in two        in two
ways.  First, in our open
payments playoff
payments
platform          platform.
This allow       allows these
devices here that I'll demo
demo here in a moment to be
able to do smart tap
interactions
interactions.  And so we're also
also happy to announce
that two     two of our partners
partners, shop keep
and by    bypass mobile will be
will be building
building smart-
smart-tap enabled experiences
through the clover platform
platform.
Secondly
Secondly, the clover      Clover
customer          customer
engagement suite       suite of
products          products,
through that suite       suite
of products          products
we'll       we'll be enabling
enabling smart tap
technology to a vast      vast
array            vast array
array of our small
businesses            businesses
in the U.S.        U.S.  We've
shipped over 5 hundred thousand
500,000
devices to small businesses
businesses in the
U.S.        U.S.  And through
this consumers
consumers and merchants will
have some fantastic
fantastic users       users
experiences.
Now, there's         there's
three things about       about
smart tap     tap that I really
like.  First is    is simplicity
simplicity.  It
doesn't get simpler than
than tapping         tapping to
earn, redeem and pay.  It can
hardly        hardly be simpler.
real value for merchants
merchants.  When a
customer          customer
customer enrolls
through         through smart
tap, what the merchant will be
will be able to do is
is push offer       offer s
offers and rewards
rewards collectly into an drad
collectly
into Android         Android
pay   Pay for those consumers
consumers.  It can also
also send offer
offers, if    if you say you
have a lapsed        lapsed
customer          customer and
you want to incent them
them to come back to your store.
store.  So and it's
really a marketing
marketing technology that I
personally            personally
want.  It's both convenient
convenient and it's in
context.  So last      lastly,
it also      also does one other
thing       thing.  It enables
all sorts       sorts of other
innovation
innovation.  You can imagine a
scenario          scenario where
you buy something online, it
could be on the mobile web, it
could be in a native
native app, and say you buy it
online and then      then you
want to redeem in store, pick it
up instore.  You can save to
Android         Android pay
Pay, come in and tap to
present         present proof of
purchase.  There's
There's many other things
things that we've been thinking
about       about online to
offline commerce
commerce that are really enabled
enabled by this.
So need to build anything
anything that touches
consumers           consumers on
the other side of the county
of the counter with
merchant technology check us
us out clover.com/
clover.com/developer
you     you, Varouj
Varouj.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:  All right
right.  Thank you, John.
clover.com/developers.  Back to
you, Varouj.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:  All right.
Thank you, John.
[ Applause ]
At this point I know two things
things for certain about
about every member of the
audience          audience here.
One, everyone
everyone can use a snack
snack, right?  And number two
two, everyone
everyone wants to check out some
of these loyalty
loyalty features in Android
Android pay   Pay that
we've been talking about
about.  Of course, right?  So
we've got something special for
you.  We've create
created a game called tap for
treats        treats.  All you
have to do is download
download the I/    I/O loyalty
loyalty card from
card and you have to
find the clover      Clover
smart tap terminals around the
venue       venue and if    if
you find all five      five of
these terminals, you will get a
limited         limited edition
Android         Android robot
that look      looks like me.
[ Laughter ]
]
It's not sold in stores
stores.  So I highly
highly encourage you do that.
And I would like to see if    if
John could       could show us
us    us how the smart tap
works
on a clover      Clover
terminal
>> terminal
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  Sure.  What I have
here is    is a tap for treats
treats.  Here I have a
customer          customer
facing        facing device.  It
happens to be based on clover
Clover OS.  And then
then on this side is    is our
merchant-
merchant-facing
merchant-facing device.  So is
I'm     I'm going to take this.
I'm     I'm simply going to
hold this here.  I'm     I'm
going to tap, you'll see here
here and that it welcome
welcomes me by name.
One thing       thing I forget
forget to mention that I
love about       about smart tap
is    is it enables additional
additional
personalization
personalization at point of sale
sale.  Over here on the
merchant side this is    is a
prototype           prototype
and what will certainly improve
this, but it has my name here.
You can imagine you can do
things        things like pull
up my previous order, the mrnt
order, the
merchant can greet me by name
and ask     ask me if    if I
want my usual.  I'm     I'm
going to check on it
to check out real
quick here.
Now I have my extra loyalty
loyalty point jvrnlths
loyalty
point jvrnlths
point.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
CHITILIAN:  John gets a treat.
This is    is a shave
shave ice from      from powder
powder and it's right
here on terminal
terminal 1 poush
terminal 1
pouch                  terminal
1 porch       porch 1.  Gerardo
Gerardo, back to you
you.
GERARDO CAPIEL:
CAPIEL:  So cool.  So hopefully
hopefully you all have
gotten        gotten a taste
taste of how we're making
payments fast      faster,
easier and safe      safer.
You've heard how we're
collaborating
collaborating with the major
payment platform
platforms visa      visa,
MasterCard            MasterCard
and pay pal, how we're scaling
scaling our solution
solution by enabling
enabling users
users to pay     pay with the
cards       cards in their
their Google account.  And
And how we're helping merchants
merchants generate
loyalty among their       their
customers through our expand
expanded poi
expanded API     APIs.
We can't do all this innovation
innovation by
yourself          yourself s
innovation ourselves
innovation
by ourselves
ourselves.  We need all of you
to participate and we thank you
for your support.  We look
look forward to working
working with you between now and
the next I/    I/O.  And just
to wrap up with some final
points        points, I'm
I'm going to turn it back to
Varouj
.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
CHITILIAN:  If you have
questions go to developer
developers.Google.com/
payments
and get information.  Also
Also these are our listing
listings for office
hours       hours and our code
labs.  So please drop by so we
can give      give you some
hands-        hands-on
experience with some of this
technology.  I would also
also      also like to direct
you to two        to two
sessions          sessions with
related         related content
content.  One is    is
for Android         Android
developer           developers
called improved
improved sign-       sign-in
payment         payment and data
data entry       entry in
your apps and one is    is for
Chrome        Chrome developer
developer s
developers called
web payments          payments,
making        making it easy for
users       users to give
give you money.        money.
So thank you very much      much
for your attention
attention and go ahead
ahead and tap for treats.  Thank
you.
[ Applause ]
>>
user get things done, whenever
they are.  In the home and on
the go.
Patrick and AJ have talked about
messaging and media apps for
integrating with auto, the
templated and notifications apps
in AJ's pyramid that want to
show a UI.  There are tons of
other aps that don't fall under
these categories.  How can you
as a developer get your
experience in the car without
having to deal with the
complexity of building a full
automotive app and having to
accommodate different screen
sizes, various inputs and
outputs?
If your service can be
voice-centric in the car and you
want a lightweight integration
for reaching these users, then
the Google Assistant is a good
option.  How do you build for
the Google Assistant?
Actions On Google is the
platform for developers to build
for the Google Assistant.  The
platform will allow developers
to reach users wherever the
assistant is available.  The
platform uses cloud execution so
users don't need to pre-install
any app when they ask for your
service by name, you'll be
connected immediately.  Many
developers are already building
for Actions On Google.  When
building for Actions On Google,
there are three key pieces that
need to be defined by the
developer.    Invocation
triggers, dialogs
dialog, and
fulfillment
fulfillment.  Let me illustrate
with an example.  I like coding
and I like fortune cookies.  So
I want to build a service that
gives me a daily dose of coding
fortune cookies.
So the first step is I needed to
find my invocation trigger.
How does the user connect to my
service?  What do they actually
have to say?  In this case I'll
make it simple, whenever the use
arer says talking coding
fortune cookie, then the Google
Assistant will connect the user
to my service.
The next step is dialogs.  So
once the user is connected to my
service, how do I talk to them?
What kind of information am I
asking and what kind of
responses am I expecting?  What
are valid responses and what are
invalid responses?  In this
case I'm going make it a simple
question do they want a Java or
a C + + fortune cookie.  So
there are only two valid
responseness this case.  So
let's suppose that the user
picked Java.  We can move on to
the third step which is
fulfillment.  For fulfillment I
have all the information that I
need, so how do I go about
committing that transaction or
computing that action on behalf
of the user so in this case I'm
going to look in my bank of Java
fortunes and I'm going to pick
one out for today.  Random one.
Today's fortune says Codefucious
says for true happiness, prefer
interfaces over abstract
classes.  That's one I actually
use every day.
That's a high level view of
Actions On Google.  The Google
assistant and Actions On Google
are coming to Android Auto and
will open up a wide possibility
of use cases.  Agents and
services that are built on top
of the platform will transfer
over.  If you think that users
will interact with your agent or
service in the car, it's a good
idea to start thinking about
what is the user experience that
you want to build for that
special context.  One
car-specific consideration is
safety and driver distraction.
How can you build a user
experience that both minimizes
driver distraction and alaw
users to get things done and
stay entertained.
Let's think about potential use
cases for engaging with users in
the car.  What is possible
here?
One idea is reservations.  It's
a Friday night and I'm meeting
up with my husband for dinner.
We pick out a restaurant and on
the way there I would love to be
able to say, book a table, and
have that table waiting for me
by the time I get there.  What
would be even more
awesome         awesome and
magical is if the Google
Assistant and that third-party
service can suggest a good
reservation time that takes into
account my location, traffic,
and maybe parking availability.
So I make a make a reservation
for a time I can definitely
make.
Another idea is food ordering.
I'm working late on a week night
and I'm too lazy to cook.  On
my way home I would love to be
able to put in an order at my
favorite restaurant and have
that food delivered and arrived
at my home by the time I get
there.  Saves on time, saves on
cooking.
Like I mentioned earlier, how
many times have you driven away
from your house and can't
remember whether you've actually
locked the front door?  It
would be very cool if you could
say okay Google, check my door.
Or did I lock my door?  Just
lock it.
Another one is lights.  I'm
driving home and I actually hate
walking into a dark house.  I'm
actually afraid of the dark.
It would be great if from the
car I could say turn on my
living room lights or turn on my
dining room lights and I never
have to walk into a dark house
again.
Games and entertainment.  How
many times have you been on long
road trips with kids where you
struggle to find a way to keep
them entertained?  Wouldn't it
be awesome if you could say okay
Google, entertain my kids and
have games that are
age-appropriate for different
kids so they can play whatever
they want.  They stay
entertained and I can focus on
the road.
These are just some ideas
ideas on ways developers can
engage with users       users in
the car.  I look forward to
what creative          creative
ideas you come up with.
with.  Please check out the
Actions On Google site where
there are actually code samples
and tools       tools to help
you build the dialog and
triggers and fulfillment steps
so that makes it easier to bring
up your service.  We also have
demos at the IoT and Android
domes.  We'll actually be
showcasing some of the use cases
that I just talked about
including controlling Hue lights
and August door locks directly
from inside the car.  Thank you
and back to pack trick.
[ Applause ]
PATRICK BRADY:  Thanks, Chen.
It's really exciting to see a
new way for developers to easily
extend their services into
cars.  With conversational voice
powered by the Google
Assistant, we hope to see many
new types of apps in use cases.
You also heard from AJ how
media and messaging apps can
extend through the car in a
scaleable way with Android Auto
templates and notifications.
Google Assistant and Android so
you can worry about building a
great app and experience for
your drivers.
This model has helped Android
Auto grow to be the largest
in-car ecosystem today, and it
about to get a whole lot bigger
with the Google Assistant.  With
10x growth in users over the
last year, and new partners like
Audi and Volvo building Android
directly into their cars, we
know that developers are going
to have plenty of eager drivers
out there who want to stay
connected on the road.  So we're
excited to continue this road
ahead with all of you, to build
the future of automotive
infotainment and criate a safe
and seamless experience for
drivers everywhere.
Thanks                                                                                                                                                                                                                                         we're
excited to continue this road
ahead with all of you, to build
the future of automotive
infotainment and criate a safe
and seamless experience for
drivers everywhere.  Thanks and
enjoy the rest of the show.
[ Applause ]
[Session concluded]
Thank you for joining this
session.  Brand ambassadors will
assist.  We'll be making room
for those of you who have
registered for the next session.
If you've registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask that you please clear the
room and return via the
registration outside.  Thank
you.
>>
>> Duncan Duncan Osborn Andre
Valente app.
>>DUNCAN OSBORN:
ANDRE VALENTE:  Blah blah pretty
blah blah blah.
ANDRE VALENTE:  Blah blah blah
Google Search immersive
SPEAKER:
>>
>> Quesadilla chevron Rakuten.
SPEAKER:  Welcome
Welcome to Google IO.  Hope you
have a great time.
You're        You're still a
wave        awave my name is
Alex Danilo        Danilo.
#50i78 very              .  I'm
very      very excited about
WebAssembly
WebAssembly.  Even though
though I love JavaScript
JavaScript as I'm
as I'm sure most
most of you do, I have to
confess I'm     I'm a real
performance
performance freak.  So I love
native        native code
juch                  native
code just as much      much.
The beauty about WebAssembly is
is that it lets      lets
developer           developers
compile from      from C and C
plus plus      plus or other
languages into that we can loud
into a web browse
browser.
Okay.  So why     why?  Why
Why do we even      even have
WebAssembly
WebAssembly?  I can tell you
probably          probably
wondering why     why you're
you're at this session.
The thing about JavaScript is
because         because it's a
dynamic         dynamic ly
dynamically typed
typed language there are
limits        limits.  Over the
past      past few years
years the engine        engines
have done amazing things
things to puch
things to push the envelope
envelope of
performance
performance.
When you think about       about
progressive
progressive web apps      apps
as a kind of switch towards a
native        native app like
experience, it's about
about better you are, it's
about       about higher
performance
performance.  One of the things
things, one of the
of the bottle        bottle
necks is    is the JavaScript
JavaScript.  So are
there any abnormal
there
there any native        native
app developer
developers in the crowd?  A show
of hands.  Not too much
hands.  Not
too many      many.
There are many millions of app
developer           developers
out in the world.  They're using
using C + +
higher performance.  One of the
things, one of the bottlenecks
is the JavaScript.  So are there
any native app developers in
the crowd?  A show of hands.
Not too many.  There are many
millions of app developers out
in the world.  They're using C +
+.  They are very      very
great library         libraries
for image       image processing
processing.  All
this kind of thing       thing.
Now imagine how it would be if
if you could       could
take your existing
existing application code for
your an drad
for your Android         Android
app or whatever and cross
compile         compile it to
deploy        deploy in a
browse        browser.  That's
what WebAssembly is    is.  It
lets      lets you take existing
existing C plis
existing C + +
it would be if you could take
your existing application code
for your Android app or whatever
and cross compile it to deploy
in a browser.  That's what
WebAssembly is.  It lets you
take existing C + + code deploy
deploy it in a brouds
broudser and have it run
what's exciting is    is all
the engine        engines are
doing it.  You don't have to
rewrite         rewrite your
code      code.  Okay.  So I
just want to start       start
with a little interdution
little
introduction
introduction to have    have.
Now take this tiny      tiny
little function here.  Let's
Let's just add in two
things together and     and
running it    it.  This is
and run
Republicaning
and returnling it.  Can nen
it.  Can anyone
here guess what happens when
JavaScript            JavaScript
sees that plu
sees that plus      plus?  It
horrify         horrifies me
whenever          whenever I
look      look at it because
because it look
looks something like this.
this.  This is    is the
this.
Because JavaScript is    is a
human written         written
language ids kind of designed
designed to be easy to
write and convenient
convenient, you have to do all
these type coercion
coercions, you have to doo
doo all these look-
look-ups.  I might be adding
adding a double
double to a string, all these
things        things have to be
dealt with by the JavaScript
JavaScript
engine        engine.  So what
happens in modern        modern
engine        engines is    is
they try really hard to shorten
shorten         shorten
this path to as small as
possible but it's really hard to
do.  So what we need is    is a
way to get closer        closer
to the middle.  WebAssembly is
is not about       about
running         running code in
WebAssembly
WebAssembly.  Nobody writes in
assembly          assembly.  On
a normal computer
computer people wrote computers
computers in the 60
in the 60s and then
60s and then
then they wrote high level
language.
All right       right.  So basic
principle           principle
of mine, if you want your code
to wrun              code to run
faster        faster, do less.
It's very      very obvious
obvious.  Very simple
simple.  When it comes
comes down to it, what I
would like ultimately is    is
to write A +
the 60s and then they wrote high
level language.
All right.  So basic principle
of mine, if you want your code
to run faster, do less.  It's
very obvious.  Very simple.
When it comes down to it, what I
would like ultimately is to
write A + B in my code and have
the +
level language.
All right.  So basic principle
of mine, if you want your code
to run faster, do less.  It's
very obvious.  Very simple.
When it comes down to it, what I
would like ultimately is to
write A + B in my code and have
the + convert to a single CPU
instruction.  That's the
ultimate aim.  That gives
gives you the limit of
optization            optization
and that's what web assembly
assembly can do.  You
can add things together
together and ends up with a
single machine instruction.
It's basically
basically at the limit of what's
possible.
This kind of portable
portable code idea of running
running on different
architecture
architectures and being
being portable          portable
has a long history
history that pre-      pre-dates
the web so I'll run through a
few earlier         earlier
attempts          attempts to
set the     the stage for
for how WebAssembly
WebAssembly does what it does.
Back in the 1970             in
the 1970s we had a thing
thing       thing called p-
p-code and it was an idea of an
abstraction
abstraction of a machine that
could then      then generate p-
p-code and this intermediate
intermediate code
would compile         compile
down to the particular
architecture
architecture on which you were
running         running.  Fast
Fast forward a few years
years later       later
we ended       ended up with byt
byte-       byte-code.  Or
the do the               Or the
dot     dot net run time.
If you look      look around in
the play store, we've done
analysis          analysis of
native apps      apps, native
apps that are     are actually
actually in the store.
If you look      look at the
top thousand apps      apps, the
vast      vast majority
majority of them      them
are using       using the native
native development kid
or the NDK.  So they compiling
compiling the C +
+
store, we've done analysis of
native apps, native apps that
are actually in the store.  If
you look at the top thousand
apps, the vast majority of them
are using the native development
kid or the NDK.  So they
compiling the C + +, the
majority of the
majority of the        of the
logic is    is in C + plution
of native apps, native apps that
are actually in the store.  If
you look at the top thousand
apps, the vast majority of them
are using the native development
kid or the NDK.  So they
compiling the C + +, the
majority of the logic is in C +
+
of native apps, native apps that
are actually in the store.  If
you look at the top thousand
apps, the vast majority of them
are using the native development
kid or the NDK.  So they
compiling the C + +, the
majority of the logic is in C +
+.  They're         They're not
using much Java      Java at
all.  The reason        reason
these people on an drad
on Android is    is
doing this is    is for
performance
performance.  But these kind of
devices are installed
installed on a closed
closed system and what we have
is    is the open web so that
brings        brings a whole new
set of challenges like security
and privacy         privacy.
There are plenty        plenty
of previous attempts
attempts to run native
native code in the browse
browsier          browser and
I'll run through them because
because it gives
gives you an idea where they're
coming from
from.  And what you can do
with it as well.  Okay.
So
So current WebAssembly
WebAssembly as it
stands today       today runs at
1.2 times the speed of
native        native code.
Which is    is an       is an
astandishing
astandishing number when you
think about       about it.
This is    is a format
format that is compiled
compiled into a sandbox
sandbox save environment.  Runs
into a whole lot of
constraints
constraints to make sure it
it has no security vulnerability
vulnerabilities
and yet
vulnerabilities and yet     yet
it's only a small slow-
slow-down.
The #250e78s              The
teams       teams are working
working really hard to
speed that up a little bit more.
But the most important
important point I want
to get home to you     you
right now is    is that
that this is    is not one
browse        browser.  All the
four browse        browser
engine        engines have done
this and they are seeing very
very similar execution
execution times.  So
this is    is really exciting
exciting.  Before we go
into the details, what did
did we learn from      from the
past      past that got us    us
to where we are?  Well, many
years       years ago the only
way              the only way to
get high performance
performance on the
web was with plug
was with plugins
plugins.  We had lots      lots
of plugins         plugins for
different things        things.
We had flash, we also      also
had Java      Java with its
virtual         virtual machine,
lots      lots of things
things like that.  Plugins
Plugins were great in
their       their day.  However
plugins aren't very      very
good for today       today.  And
the reason is    is, even
even when we put a pliven
put a plugin
plugin into a sand      sandbox
environment, we still cop
security who else
cop security
holes.  It's really hard to
control.            control.
The other thing is    is that
plugin        plugins do not
play nicely        nicely with
the web poi             the web
API     APIs.  We have lots
lots of web API     APIs we
have mowing                we
have
motion detection
detection, stuff you can do with
the camera        camera.  A
lot that are native
native to the browse
browser, but you can't get that
from      from the plugins
plugins.  And so this
kind of
of disjoint model       model
doesn't work well.  But the
single reason plugins aren't
aren't a          aren't
a great idea is    is these
things        things.  They just
don't run on mobile.  So it's
very      very hard to give
give your users       users a
performant   ant experience from
from a plugin
plugin that doesn't exist
exist.  On top of that
people have to install
plugin        plugins.  And we
moved       moved on later
later to this thing       thing
that Google built       built
called native        native
client.  So what native
native client was, it was a
target for compiled
compiled code.  To run in the
web krouz                  in
the web browse        browser.
So it was a sand      sandboxed
compile         compiler target.
So it was safe      safer than
than proper native
native code.  Ran pretty fast
fast but again it had the
limitations
limitations that it didn't
didn't talk to other web API
APIs so didn't
didn't really work with your
dumb objects.  And it only ran
in Chrome        Chrome, which
is    is one browse
browser.  We tried       tried
for a few years       years to
evolve        evolve this.  We
developed           developed
portable          portable
native        native client.  If
you remember portable
portable native        native
client, that actually
actually let you target
target        target in
intermediate
intermediate code that could be
compiled          compiled on
the client               on the
client side.  That has its own
set of problems
problems.  Once you have the
compile         compiler in the
browse        browser, that
could be vulnerable
vulnerable to security holes so
you have to put the compile
compiler itself
itself into a sandbobs
sandbox.  It was an incredibly
incredibly complex
architecture
architecture and none of the
of the web browse
browsers wanted to do it because
because it was too
too difficult.
So along came a few smart guys
with a research praj
a research
project         project.  The
early thing       thing of
asm     asm.js        asm.js.
So what asm     asm.js
asm.js does is    is it takes
takes C +
+
complex architecture and none of
the web browsers wanted to do
it because it was too difficult.
with a research project.  The
early thing of asm.js.  So what
asm.js does is it takes C + +,
compile         compiles it down
into a tiny      tiny subset of
JavaScript
JavaScript that contains
contains a bunch of
annotations
annotations and the JavaScript
JavaScript engine
engines attempt to
compile         compile that
into fast      fast native
native code.  However
However one of the
of the limitations
limitations of asm     asm.js is
is the different engine
engines ran with
different performance
performance.  So
let's       let's just see how s
how asmm      asmm.js
asmm.js and WebAssembly
WebAssembly differ
in the world.  This is    is an
example         example of an as
m        an asm.js is    is an
output.  This first line of the
of the function, that's a
hint telling         telling
the JavaScript
JavaScript engine        engine
that that is    is an integer
integer.  So that ng
So that can help
compile because         because
it's explicitly
explicitly annotate
annotated.
annotated.  But to understand
why WebAssembly is    is a
better model than      than this
or a fast      faster model
model, we have to look
look at how JavaScript
JavaScript engine
works       works and what it
does when it sees this.
this.
So within V8, any JavaScript
JavaScript program
you write, this is    is the
first thing       thing that
happens.  On the left we have
some JavaScript
JavaScript source containing
containing a bunch of
JavaScript
JavaScript functions
functions.  The first thing
thing we need to do is
pass.  And generates
generates this thing       thing
called an abstract
abstract syntax        syntax
tree.  The abstract
tree is    is a representation
of the logic       logic of your
program.            program.
Once yeef      yeef generated
generated this
internal representation, you
then      then go straight to
machine code.  But that's a very
fast      fast operation and
there is    is no real attempt
made      made to speed that up.
If
If we take all of that and
squish        squish it up and
go to the next surgeon
surgeon, this is    is what the
VI pipeline          pipeline
does.  We have this thing
thing called turbo       turbo
fan.  What happens is    is the
steps       steps in the
beginning there to the left,
where the first red blob is
is, while your JavaScript
JavaScript
application is    is running
running, there's
there's a lot of code inside V8
and        V8 and other engines
engines do similar
things        things, looking
looking at what's running
running slow, looking
looking at the hot
functioning                 hot
functions           functions
going this one is    is bad and
when we identify
identify slow functions
functions, we then
then reoptimize them
them.  So we push them      them
through this back end here
which is    is an optimize
optimize ed
optimized.  The one thing
thing I want to emphasize
emphasize here is    is
that this action of analyze ing
analyzing the code
and deciding          deciding
what to optimize
optimize, that will cost
cost CPU cycle           CPU
cycles and that means it uses
battery on the mobile device.
In the asm            In the
asm.js        asm.js case it
woms      woms in through the
pasm      pasm stage.  If you
use WebAssembly, it look
looks like this.
So what happens is    is the
WebAssembly
WebAssembly has already
already gone through optimize
ation              optimization
through the compile
compile face.  There is no pause
as such      such.  So we're
seening                  So
we're seeing        seeing 10 or
12 seconds         seconds load
time for a reasonably size
sized application.  So you
eliminate that pause time.  And
what you have is    is optimize
optimized b
binary        binary which would
generate the machine code and
all the optimize ation
optimizations have
been done by the compile
compiler at the front
end.  So this particular picture
within V8 shows       shows
what happens is    is when you
load the JavaScript
JavaScript engine        engine
and load the web assembly
the web
WebAssembly
WebAssembly module        module
we can compile         compile
the whole thing       thing in
one hit and everything runs
runs at full speed.  Some other
JavaScript
JavaScript engine        engines
like chakra        chakra and
edge take           edge take a
different approach.  They leave
leave the module
module in memory and the first
time a function is    is called
they compile         compile it
at that point.  So they kind of
trade it ahead       ahead of
time compile delay       delay
with small hiccup        hiccups
on the way.
Anyway.  Moving        Moving
on.  I'll just kind of try and
explain WebAssembly
WebAssembly as a concept now.
So what actually is    is it.
And the one thing       thing
I've been asked       asked
multiple times in the last
last few days is    is does this
mean we don't have to write
JavaScript            JavaScript
anymore and the answer is    is
no.  Not it's a complement to
JavaScript
JavaScript.  It's a way for
people to take C + +
asked multiple times in the last
few days is does this mean we
don't have to write JavaScript
anymore and the answer is no.
Not it's a complement to
JavaScript.  It's a way for
people to take C + + or C or
rust      rust code or any other
type of language and compile
compile it down to a
module        module that you
can call from JavaScript
JavaScript.  So they
work together          together.
together.
One of the things is also
also when we were developing
developing this was
that people realize
realized the short#k078g
shortcoming      comings
of native        native client.
It was developed
developed by the same people.
The people that built
people.  They all worked
together          together to
build what we have today
today.
So what we actually
actually do with it is    is,
it's tightly         tightly
integrated            integrated
into the web platform
platform.  It's a new capability
capability.  You
have to think of it as that.
It's not meant to replace
JavaScript
JavaScript.  It also      also,
that also      also means you
can talk to all the web API
APIs.  You can call all the
standard dumb functions
functions or all the
API     APIs from      from your
web asem reply
web asem blii
from your WebAssembly
WebAssembly code.
It does have a few differences.
And in the future there's
there's a plan to add
threading           threading
and multiple instruction at the
same time.  So it's kind of it
in a small nutshell
nutshell.
But I'm about       about to go
through a through technical
slides        slides that are
very      very dry and boring
boring so feel free to go
to sleep for the next four
slides        slides if you're
if you're not a total
geek      geek.  This is pretty
much      much the goals
goals of the design of
WebAssembly
WebAssembly.  The first thing
thing was to be smaller than
asm     asm.js        asm.js.
Right now the WebAssembly
WebAssembly module is
is smaller than
smaller over the wire.  It
wanted to be easy to verify
verify.  We're not
talking about       about verify
verify.  What that means
is    is verifying
verifying that the program is
safe      safe.  This is    is
actually          actually
designed          designed to be
run in a kind of sandbongs
sandbox environment.
So one of those things
things with running
running in a sand      sandbox
is    is that you can't let
stray       stray accesses out
of the        of the memory of
the        of the executing
executing program
happen.  So affect
happen.  So
effective           effectively
you can run through the
WebAssembly b
WebAssembly binary        binary
code and validate there are no
accesses outside of the
of the bounds of the        of
the memory block it's contained
contained in.  You
don't have to do it that way,
but it is possible in the
design.  Same thing       thing
for the compilation
compilation.  You should be able
to compile         compile it
with one pass through the file.
As I said before, other
JavaScript            JavaScript
engine        engines have
chosen        chosen to compile
compile piece by piece
for their       their own design
reasons         reasons.
The other thing is also
also it needs       needs to be
extensible
extensible.  So right now there
are very      very small number
number of primitive
primitives, which I'll
show you in a minute, but the
whole design        design was
built       built around adding
adding new thiijs
adding new
things        things later
later.
So let's       let's take a look
look at the basic
basics of the        of the
memory model       model.  This
is    is a little bit of a scary
scary slide, that's why
why I warned        warned
you in advance.  But basically
basically the memory
for a C + +
the whole design was built
around adding new things later.
basics of the memory model.
This is a little bit of a scary
slide, that's why I warned you
in advance.  But basically the
memory for a C + + program
compiled          compiled into
WebAssembly look      looks like
a type to JavaScript
a typed array
array to JavaScript
JavaScript.  One of the
of the features
features of WebAssembly
WebAssembly that
helps with security is    is
this concept of an execution
stack       stack, which is
is separate from      from the
linear        linear memory.  So
if you think about       about
a normal C + +
program compiled into
WebAssembly looks like a typed
array to JavaScript.  One of the
features of WebAssembly that
helps with security is this
concept of an execution stack,
which is separate from the
linear memory.  So if you think
about a normal C + + program,
you have a heap      heap.  And
you allocate memory from
from the bottom of the heap
heap and you grow the stack
from      from the top of the
heap      heap.  And it's
possible to take a pointer
pointer and look
look up into the stack
stack memory and start playing
playing with variable
variables that you're
you're not supposed to be
playing         playing with and
do all sorts       sorts of
nefarious things.  WebAssembly
WebAssembly has a
completely            completely
different model       model.
The execution stack is    is
isolated from      from the
WebAssembly
WebAssembly program itself
itself so there is no way
you can actually
actually poke into it and change
things.           things.  That
's a really cool security
feature         feature.
Also
Also the functions
functions themselves
themselves, these integer
integer offset
offsets.  They don't actually
actually have pointers.
They're         They're
numbered functions
functions which point into a
table.  And those indirect
calculated numbers jump
jump into the functions
functions themselves
inside the module        module.
And the reason        reason
it's built       built that way
is    is so that you can load
multiple modules         modules
side by side so you offset
offset all the index
indexes and everything
works beautiful
beautifully.
One of the things        things
that is very important
important to point out here as
well is    is that the
WebAssembly
WebAssembly module        module
has no access to any plemple
to any platform
API     APIs.  So back in the
bad old days of plug
days of plugins
plugins you can call any
API     API you wanted.
WebAssembly
WebAssembly has no such
such access.  Everything is
is mediated          mediated
through JavaScript
JavaScript which means you're
you're in control and
basically JavaScript is    is
the boss and WebAssembly
WebAssembly just
does the job it's told
to.
So here's what we look      look
at the        at the memory
when we compile         compile.
There is no direct addressing
addressing, all the
pointer         pointer
addresses can be        can be
bounced         bounced checked.
What that means is    is you
actually          actually have
have a big address number.  You
have an offset        offset.
Since we know the block of
memory is    is this big, we can
very      very quickly
quickly check that that number
falls in that range to guarantee
guarantee that we're
not outside our memory block.
That also      also means that
that check is    is cheap.  When
jumping         jumping into a
function, to do that little
bounds check is    is really
trivial         trivial.  And
also      also one of the
of the other features
features of this is    is at the
moment when assembly
assemblies of 32 address space.
So if you're           if
you're running         running
on a 64 bit device you can load
the WebAssembly
WebAssembly module        module
into memory, put two     two
hardware          hardware
guards on each set of the
of the address space and if
anything          anything was
going to escape        escape
the 32 bit address space, you
get that safety        safety at
0      at 0 run     runtime
costs       costs.  Which is
is a fantastic
fantastic ability
ability.          ability.
So this is pretty much      much
WebAssembly
WebAssembly in a nutshell
nutshell.  This is
is all we have.         have.
One page.  One slide.  So I'll
quickly         quickly run
through.  As I pointed
pointed out before, the 64 bit
integer         integers are a
great thing       thing for C +
+
So this is pretty much
WebAssembly in a nutshell.  This
is all we have.  One page.  One
slide.  So I'll quickly run
through.  As I pointed out
before, the 64 bit integers are
a great thing for C + +.  It's
not available in JavaScript
JavaScript.  The
functions           functions
are
bound, I talked about
about the direction for the call
in.  And we have a bunch of
standard operations
operations.  All the standard
operations            operations
you would expect on integer
integers, adding
adding, subtraction
subtraction, multiplication
multiplication,
shifting          shifting.
Also      Also contains
square root and float and
ceiling         ceiling and it's
pretty much      much
conversion
conversions to do casting
casting.  It's kind of a
load store model       model.
The actual WebAssembly
WebAssembly virtual
virtual machine model is
is a stack       stack
machine.  So if    if people
have heard of virtual machines
machines, there are two
types       types.  There are
stack machines          machines
and there are registered-
registered-based
virtual machines
machines.  It's actually
actually a stack
stacked machine based model
model.  And there's
there's a bunch of
structured            structured
control flow that's brought
brought on yadda ya
yadda yadda       yadda.
what you're        you're all
here for.  Can you use
this stuff.  And the answer
is    is a resounding
resounding yes.  This is    is
monumental            monumental
to get four      four large
browse                   four
large browse        browser
engine        engines to work
together          together to
bring       bring something t
t market.  It's really amazing
amazing.  And at the
moment these engine
engines like Chrome
Chrome implements the binary
binary format
format.  But at the moment
there's         there's a lot of
work going on about       about
integrating
integrating with post message
for web asem reply
for web
assembly          assembly
module        modules and being
being able to install them
them index       index DB.
In the works       works
there's         there's a stream
ing API     API and on the
priority          priority left
as well.
As far as tools       tools you
people are developer
developers love developer tools
I'm hoping        hoping anyway.
In any way
anyway.  In any case, LLVM is
is the compile
compiler of choice today
today.  There are actually
actually a lot of
schools there are things
things called em script
script ennen
called em
em script em which people
may be familiar with.  There's
There's another cool
called by    binaryen
binaryen.  It's a stand
standalone     alone tool but
could be used      used with
other compile         compilers
such      such as GCC.  There
are other tools       tools as
well that take the binary
binary format        format and
disassemble
disassemble it into something
that's human readable and vice
versa       versa.  There are
lots      lots of things
things you can play with if you
want to experiment.  If you're
If you're a really hard
hardcore developer
developer you might
want to have a look      look at
the
the.
The W
The W3C is    is working
working         working on
formalize ing
formalizing the spec.  This
standard was developed
developed through a W     a W3C
community group, which is
group, which
isn't                    group,
which is    is an easy forum
forum to get started with
new features          features.
So now that we've progressed to
implementation
implementations, it's moving
moving to a working
working group for proper
formalization
formalization.
Okay.  So I'm     I'm just going
to do a bref demo      demos.
This is    is    is the Conway
Conway's game of life is
is one of these classic games
games.  And what's cool
about       about it is    is
it's one of the        of the
first things        things you
learn       learn in computer
science         science.  The
reason        reason I wanted to
show it to you is because
because I had a good
friend of mine      mine an
engineer          engineer
called Sam who     who decided
decided he would try to
make it as small as    as
possible as WebAssembly
WebAssembly module
module to prove
something.  So he compiled
compiled it without the
standard C library
library and the WebAssembly
WebAssembly module
is two k   kilobyt
kilobytes           kilobytes.
I'll show you it running
running.
This is basically
basically a simple        simple
game of life and it's running
running here in Chrome
Chrome and as you can see
the performance is    is not so
fast      fast.  The little
glider is gliig       gliig down
the bottom there.  You get a
rough idea how fast      fast
that runs.  So that's pretty
good.
Now of course if    if this was
a one browse        browser
story       story it would be
not a very interesting story.
story.  So so we'll light
up Firefox         Firefox
here.  And Firefox is    is
lighting          lighting up
up the WebAssembly
WebAssembly module        module
running         running the
same code
performance is basically
basically identical
identical.  Two browse
browser engines
engines.  Already
engines.  All right
right.
Here we have sfary
have safari        safari and lo
lo and behold it's running
as well.  The same module
module, running beautiful
beautifully.  Not a
problem whatsoever
whatsoever.  You'll notice here
that execution
execution speed is basically
basically identical
identical between all of
them      them.  And just to
round out the four          the
four, I'll run it in a virtual
virtual machine in edge
Edge.  This runs a little bit
slower only because
because it's within a virtual
virtual machine but it
is edge    Edge and it works
works.  So this, I just
want to bring       bring home
the point --
point --
[ Applause ]
and
it works.  So this, I just want
to bring home the point --
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
So I just wanted to show that
this is    is a real thing
thing and it actually
actually does run in all browse
browsers.
If    If we could       could
switch back to a slide for one s
sec.  So this is    is
another demo      demo.  This is
is another classic computer
science         science 10
101, which is    is a manned l
will             manned will
brat                  manned
is a manned he
is a Mand
a Mandelbrot              a
Mandelbrot set.  It's the
perfect candidate
candidate for a WebAssembly
WebAssembly module
module.  This is    is in
C.          is in C + +
browsers.  If we could switch
back to a slide for one sec.  So
this is another demo.  This is
another classic computer science
101, which is a Mandelbrot set.
It's the perfect candidate for
a WebAssembly module.  This is
in C + +.  Can we switch it to
the laptop again
please?  And so this is yufr
yufr classic Mandelbrot
Mandelbrot.  I'll
click through and start zooming
zooming         zooming
in on it to give      give you
the idea how fast      fast the
computation is    is.
This is    is how fast
fast I can run it using
WebAssembly
WebAssembly.  It would be nice
to compare to JavaScript
JavaScript, but in
any case if    if anyone has
played with this stuff before
they would understand
understand.
Prach
understand.  Switch back to the
slides        slides again.
One more little gem
more little demo
demo for you and this is
is fantastic
fantastic.  This is    is a
wonderful           wonderful
open source community project.
It's by someone who
someone whose
project.  It's
called web DSP.  And what this
actually is is    is a browse
browser.  This will
showcase what you can really do
with WebAssembly
WebAssembly.  Can we hit the
laptop again please?  So what
this is    is, this is    is
like live video just play it in
the brousz                  it
in the browse        browser.
The right-hand side      side we
have these graphs.  Right now
we're just playing
playing the video.
This is    is amazing
amazing, it has a whole lot of
little effects.  Doing edge
edge detection
detection.  This is    is all
running         running
running in a WebAssembly
WebAssembly module
module.
Nk             module.  To
prove it's not a canned demo
demo, we can actually
actually switch to a
web cam.  I can do things
things to myself and make
myself look      look horrible.
Do kind of like edge de
dedetection
dedetection.  We're still
pulling 58 frames        frames
a second with web assembly
assembly.  Fantastic
Fantastic.  Back to
the slides
slides.
The WebAssembly
WebAssembly video edit
editor, jip on that web address
and have a look      look if you
like.  Also      Also we have
an open source project at Google
which is    is all about
about compressing
compressing 3-    3-D.  So it's
a great thing       thing to
use.  And the team that was
building          building it
have done a whole lot     lot of
bench marking         marking.
What you're seeing
seeing at the top is their
WebAssembly
WebAssembly code compiled
compiled and the bottom
is asm     asm.js        asm.js.
The whole point of showing
showing you this is
is that this is    is actually
actually quite a
really intense thing
thing.  Like really amazing
amazing.  And it decodes
decodes the model
model in 12s seconds
seconds but asm     asm.js takes
takes 18 seconds
seconds.  The point of this is
WebAssembly
WebAssembly runs in two-thirds
of the        of the time as the
ee equilibrium
as the
equivalent asm     asm.js
asm.js.  This is    is just the
run time.  Virtual past
Virtual pass time
is    is not county
is not counted
counted here and that's
much      much, much      much
here.
Enough
Enough of my talking
talking and demoing
demoing.  I guess you probably
probably want to work
out how you can build a
WebAssembly
WebAssembly medicinual
medicinual for
modelual for your application.
If you want to get set up on
your development machine.  The
Mandelbrot            Mandelbrot
demo      demo and Conway
Conway game, while you're
you're here go over and
have a go.  Otherwise
Otherwise when you get home you
can get it set up on your own
machine.  So right now the
compile         compiler is
is your best      best friend.
So if you visit       visit this
link, download
download the compile
compilers, build a tool chain.
Once you've installed
installed it and built
built it all, you probably
probably want to do
something with C lus
with C + +
you get home you can get it set
up on your own machine.  So
right now the compiler is your
best friend.  So if you visit
this link, download the
compilers, build a tool chain.
Once you've installed it and
built it all, you probably want
to do something with C + + code.
Once you've done this, it's
pretty easy.
Here are two     two command
lines, one to build a C filesen
a C file and one to
build a C + +
chain.  Once you've installed it
and built it all, you probably
want to do something with C + +
code.  Once you've done this,
it's pretty easy.
Here are two command lines, one
to build a C file and one to
build a C + + file.  It's as
easy as that.  It's all you have
to do.  The minus       minus S
in the command line there,
that's the thing       thing
that tells       tells
emscripten            emscripten
to generate WebAssembly
WebAssembly module
modules.  The output of
this will be two
will be two files.  Hello
Hello.js          Hello.js
contains all the gu        the
gui code so it makes       makes
it all semple               it
all simple        simple and
I'll show you how you call the
module        module.
So here is    is like what you
you put inside your C++
C++ code something like this.
If you want to pass data
data in and out you can use a
thing       thing called bind.
In this thing               In
this this case we're exporting
exporting a function
called my function and from
from that function we're
returning           returning a
returning a type to
memory view.  A JavaScript
JavaScript that will
look      look like a typed
array       array.  The beauty
beauty of this when you
pass the memory from Dr.
from C + +
In this this case we're
exporting a function called my
function and from that function
we're returning a type to memory
view.  A JavaScript that will
look like a typed array.  The
beauty of this when you pass the
memory from C + + back to
JavaScript            JavaScript
land, there's         there's
no copy yg         copying
copying.  It's just a
direct access.  It's a rivrns
rivrns.  So inside your
actual        actual file you
put a script like this.  It
creates         creates a thing
thing called module
module.  So when you call in
your function you go module
module.m          module.my
function in this case the wid
wid and height
case the width and
height and that data variable
is    is a reference that I can
work with.  Of course you might
want to do the opposite.
Because         Because of
course this is    is part of the
part of the web
platform          platform.  And
one of the        of the beauty
beauties of WebAssembly
is    is that you can interact
with all of the        of the
web API     APIs that already
exist       exist.  Here's a
fairly simple example
example of using       using
EMASM which is    is a chunk
chunk of JavaScript
JavaScript that gets
called from      from the code.
You can also      also directly
map your C + +
interact with all of the web
APIs that already exist.  Here's
a fairly simple example of
using EMASM which is a chunk of
JavaScript that gets called from
the code.  You can also
directly map your C + + classes
to JavaScript
JavaScript objects and you can
input JavaScript
JavaScript function names into
the C + +
APIs
that already exist.  Here's a
fairly simple example of using
EMASM which is a chunk of
JavaScript that gets called from
the code.  You can also
directly map your C + + classes
to JavaScript objects and you
can input JavaScript function
names into the C + + code.
code.  It require
requires a little more boiler
boiler plate code but
that's perfect         perfectly
possible.
So there are a bunch of really
cool resources here.  If you
want to follow up a little more.
The main site is    is
WebAssembly.org
WebAssembly.org which contains
contains the tools
tools, documentation
documentation,
example         examples, lots
lots of stuff, some great
demo      demos.  If you want to
be involved          involved
in the design, know a little
more about       about the
anytime I gritty        gritty
technical
about the
detail        detail, go to the
designer          designer
repository
repository, which is    is quite
scary       scary but you might
find it interesting
interesting.  And if you want
to get involved
involved with the community,
because         because the
community is    is where it was
originally developed
developed.  And it's a friendly
friendly environment.
You can go in and ask     ask
questions and get answers
answers or make
suggestions for future changes.
In any case, when you first
build yourself          yourself
a   a nice WebAssembly
WebAssembly module
module, and you import it
into your app, whether it's a
progressive
progressive web app or not, it's
if              not, if    if
it's a progressive
progressive web app you know
what your users       users are
going to say to you     you?  I
can't believe that's not a
native        native app.
Anyway, with that I'll open the
floor for questions.  And thank
you.
[ Applause ]
There's two microphones
microphones.  If you
want to go up to the microphone
microphone.  That
will would make it
microphone.
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  How about       about
mobile?
ANDRE VALENTE:
>>
There's two microphones.  If you
want to go up to the
microphone.
SPEAKER:  How about mobile?
>> Yes,
[ Applause ]
There's two microphones.  If you
want to go up to the
microphone.
SPEAKER:  How about mobile?
>> Yes, it runs on mobile.
mobile.
Audience       UDIENCE:   :  You
showed        showed an example
example of how to call
native        native concept.
What about       about if you
want to call JavaScript
JavaScript and get an
object back from JavaScript
JavaScript and
manipulate it in native
native code say call document
get element by ID and manipulate
the element?
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  Right now there is no
support for those kinds
kinds of objects passing between
web assembly          assembly
and JavaScript
JavaScript.  It's just integer
integers and numbers
numbers.  That is    is
on the road map to the future
but right now language doesn't
know how to deal with JavaScript
makes       makes that
difficult.  Thank you.
you.
Audience
Audience:
Audience:  What if you want to
have more than one module
module?
>>
just integers and numbers.  That
is on the road map to the
future but right now language
doesn't know how to deal with
JavaScript makes that difficult.
Thank you.
Audience:  What if you want to
have more than one module?
SPEAKER:
SPEAKER:  You can have as much
have as many as you
like.  You can load within the
same address space and they're
they're moveable
effective           effectively
so you can load and modules
modules can talk to other
modules         modules as well
quite easily.         easily.
Audience
Audience       UDIENCE:  Hi
Hi, WebAssembly plus      plus
will do something like fun gap
gap or apatchy